Weirdos like zone healers are fucking freaks who are doing strange things that
really relies on someone believing in it.
And if someone does believe in it,
then the placebo effect does kind of has some effect.
But you don't want to rely on that fucking thing.
It's nice to know that there's actually some shit going on and not just,
you know,
I think I feel it right.
The big one for me has always been forming sentences.
Cause obviously I talk for a living,
I talk for a living form sentences for a living and my ability to recall words
and to pull words up instantaneously.
It's critical when dealing with hecklers at a comedy club,
when recalling material,
when recalling techniques or going over techniques during a UFC card,
when,
you know,
trying to reference something during a podcast,
like that's so giant.
And for most people,
for everything,
when you're talking to a girl and you're in a business meeting,
when you're in an interview and you're just out hanging out,
it's nice to be able to knock off.
Oh yeah.
You know,
and have to think about that,
those dull moments.
You know,
we've all had those dull moments when you just woke up,
when someone's talking to you on the phone and you're,
um,
you know,
it's that thing like I do those fucking radio interviews sometimes,
man.
Uh,
and a lot of times I'll do these radio tours,
like start at like six o'clock in the morning when I wake up,
like for UFC and stuff like that,
I have to call up all these different radio stations and for the first 40
minutes I'm a fucking moron,
man.
It's like,
it's so hard to fire up and it's like,
that's one thing that's like,
it's so critical to highlight.
Your brain is not a static state.
It's just not.
It's constantly moving and flowing and what things like Alpha brain can do along
with,
of course,
meditation,
proper thinking techniques,
how to manage your consciousness,
managing your mind.
They can get you or keep you in a,
in a,
in a more positive frequency and better,
a better vibration,
a better,
a better Rpm,
you know,
quicker Rpm,
then you would
a better frequency for what you're trying to do.
I mean,
you're dragging yourself out of sleep,
which is theta state,
which is really low.
And sometimes Delta state,
if you're a really good sleeper,
which is at the very bottom part of the frequency,
and you're trying to drag yourself back out to that without,
and getting in the optimal frequency,
it's tough.
But yeah,
these things can,
and we've shown it now with these studies,
help get you in that optimal brainwave frequency,
which is pretty Rad.
It's very exciting.
And the Boston Center for memory,
they did,
they try to bunch of different shit this year that didn't do anything.
Yeah,
yeah.
This,
so they,
Alpha brain broke a streak of 14 straight clinical trials from both
pharmaceuticals and nutraceuticals that showed zero results.
So when they came back with the results,
they were like pretty surprised and pretty stoked because they're used to just
doing these trials and they report every single one.
If it came back negative,
they'd run the report and they're,
they're,
they're pros.
You know,
they're used to doing this.
And a Alpha brain broke that streak of 14 in a row that came back,
no results.
So they were fired up.
Especially because this is an,
this is a product that has earth grow,
nutrient ingredients,
natural ingredients,
natural ingredients
on a healthy population and statistical significance,
you know,
really extremely rare according to them,
uh,
from what they've seen.
And so it's a pretty fired up.
Isn't it hilarious that so many different things that we could consider earth
grown nutrients,
you know,
natural ingredients,
natural ingredients you looked upon,
like what is that going to do?
Yeah,
yeah.
Like,
like most of what you putting in your body,
it's supposed to be that staff.
I mean,
that's literally the building blocks of your fucking sells is,
is,
is vegetable matter,
plant matter protein that earth grow nutrients.
That's what's your,
your Maytag.
How do we get bigger?
We get bigger because we eat these things and it becomes us.
You know?
But it's funny that those things,
I mean especially I'm not alpha brain obviously because it's not illegal,
but fuck,
if they had found out about it a long time ago,
it probably would have been illegal.
Cannabis,
uh,
is uh,
something that,
of course everyone that listens to this podcast knows pretty much how I feel
about marijuana and how important I think it is for humanity.
But it's really a,
it's hitting home with me right now because I have a good friend whose mom has
stage four cancer.
They took her off chemotherapy,
they put her on a CBD oil,
they put her on hand,
Boyle.
And I'm not suggesting anybody do this by the way,
if you know someone who's on cancer and you listen to your fucking doctor,
okay,
do whatever your doctor tells you to do.
However,
I just want to tell you what is happening.
My friend,
cause his mom,
they pulled her off chemotherapy because they said she was too weak.
I said,
she can't do this anymore.
So he's panicking.
He's like,
she's got a few months to live.
He gets her on that hemp oil or the cannabis oil.
Yeah.
Her tumors shrank 30% inside of a month,
30% she sleeps every night where she couldn't sleep before she eats all the
time.
Her appetite is back,
she sleeps,
her appetite is back and her tumor has shrunk by 30 fucking percent inside of a
month.
That's awesome.
And it shows just how like improving things a little bit can start a positive
cascade.
Like you improve just enough to sleep and then the sleep starts improving
things.
And then once you sleep enough,
you can eat more.
And that starts improving things.
So even if the cannabis was only a 10% increase,
maybe that got her to sleep and then maybe the sleep got her to eat and then all
of a sudden it starts going on down the line and making a big improvement.
Yeah,
I mean,
you can't discount any of the,
the factors,
you know,
even the chemotherapy,
any of the things that she was doing.
But the fact that the cannabis helped her so much helped her sleep,
helped her eat and that in most states,
except for what,
18 now it's illegal.
And in Colorado right now,
they're trying to get people to,
uh,
the,
sheriff's department and some form of a other form of police department there.
They're trying to sue the state because they said they're upholding a state and
federal laws and they're not allowed to uphold the federal law against
marijuana.
Why?
Because they're fucking arrests are down.
The rest are down.
They're panicking.
They're going to have to lay off cops there.
They're violent crime is down by like something like 15%.
They have the lowest incidents of drunk driving they've ever had in the state
and they're making fuckloads of money off of tax dollars.
Cannabis is taxed at 39%
in Colorado.
That's crazy.
They're making so much money.
They had to give some back.
Right?
Yeah.
It's hilarious.
Well,
we're going to start selling marijuana eventually,
but right now we're selling alpha for,
so got on a.com bubble and n I t use the Codeword Rogan and you'll save 10% off
any and all supplements.
Any other Onnit shit.
Cyber fall is all kinds of cool shit going on.
But yeah,
we'll get on with the pocket.
We got a lot of cool shit including this stuff.
What does this Maka Shit I'm drinking.
Yeah,
that's macho,
Macho Chai Latte.
So a ton of Tumeric in there.
Some matcha green tea,
a lot of health benefits.
Real whole spice Chai Macia at some really good drinks.
You feel like a hippie makes you want to be around people that have incense and
be like,
it's some sort of macrame project going on back home.
Some,
some carpet that's weird and weird.
Weird earthy colors people.
Yeah,
I'm done with a lot of hippies.
but just a few hippies and fucking ruined it for everybody else or hippies.
A tried too hard.
God Damn.
It's like they're like the Vegan version of hippies.
Yeah.
Well yeah.
Right.
Like to just overzealous.
But that's with everything,
man.
I mean that's like the MMA dudes that wear those fucking tee shirts on it.
You know what?
The skulls that have bullet holes in them and you know,
strangling chickens like it's always some fucking guys.
They get it too far.
Yeah.
Instead of just being there showing and as soon as he started showing,
then it's a problem.
That's what it is with everything though,
right?
I mean pretty much with everything there is in this world.
What am I looking for here?
Wonderful.
I don't know.
Should we cue the music?
Yeah.
What do we do that still?
Yeah,
we kind of do that still.
Yeah.
Boom.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
All Day.
I'm really worried that I lost my wallet.
That's the word.
Is it out there?
Yeah.
Go check out their jammies.
See if we could find it out there.
I don't think it is out there though.
I think it's a,
I think I left it on a table in a restaurant.
It's very possible when you have kids,
dude,
you lose your fucking mind cause you don't know what you're doing at any given
time.
You always like,
hey,
don't eat that.
Put that down.
Don't stick your finger in there.
That's electrical.
Don't,
don't chew on wires.
Don't put that away.
Don't get like the cars are coming.
Get over here.
You're wrangling.
So I don't have a wallet right now,
so hopefully somebody knows where it is.
We'll find out.
Jamie's taking too long because if it was out there,
he would have found it.
We might be fucked.
Well,
yeah,
it's the worst feeling ever,
but it all works out.
Yeah.
The only problem is I feel like I should do something about it before this
restaurant closes.
Nothing.
Okay.
Pause it.
We're going to be right back.
I'm gonna check my truck real quick.
Sorry.
You're worried about me.
That isn't that funny,
man.
Like some pieces of paper,
some little cards you have on your wall to have your id on.
I'm like,
oh no.
What if I get pulled over?
It's going to take me to jail.
I read a horrible story,
but a dude who's going to jail because he's a garbage man and he was picking up
the garbage before 7:00 AM so they gave him a citation.
He goes in to deal with the citation and I don't know what he did.
Have you reached some agreement with a core or talk to someone and didn't
understand the ramifications and they fucking sentenced him to 30 days in jail.
Oh,
that's fair for that.
That's justice.
And you know I,
I watched people like defended online wounds picking up the garbage for people
who have a choose to put it out like what?
You think it's okay to put that guy in a cage.
You could put them in a cage and apparently they're allowing him to work during
the week and he's got a service 30 days on weekends.
So everybody's got a family,
wife,
kids,
the whole deal.
Like most of a year.
Yeah,
30 weekends out of the year.
How fucking insane is that?
How insane is that?
They were arresting this guy,
putting them in jail because he picked up the garbage early.
What a weird world we live in,
man.
It is.
I think we're going to look back at this time and we're just going to shake our
head and think we did some weird shit in this period.
Good.
Just like we look back now 50 years ago,
a hundred years ago,
I mean people were giving each other Labatt homies back a long time and that's
where they stick an ice pick in the corner of your eye and thrash it around.
Like I haven't done what they doing.
They just trying to destroy shit.
And that was like going to prove therapy along with electro shock and all this
weird shit.
You know,
we'll look at some of the judicial system we haven't be like,
what were we thinking?
Yeah.
Well,
do you remember?
Um,
there was,
um,
a documentary on hunter s Thompson and a,
in the documentary,
it was a,
I forget who was supporting for president,
but the vice president,
it was a scandal,
like as they were running for president,
found out that he had gone through electric shock therapy.
He'd gone,
he had had a few moments.
We're shit didn't work out right with his brain.
And so they decided to juice this guy up with,
I mean,
what,
what is that?
The bath,
that's like the equivalent of smacking your TV when the,
you know,
when the reception's not coming in,
just walk up to and fucking smack it and it works.
You're like,
oh,
okay.
Such a crude instrument to use
full on.
It's not like they're targeting anything.
You know,
like Dave Asprey might be doing now.
I mean he's still may not know exactly what he's doing,
but at least he has an idea of a goal going forward.
When he's Zapping his brain,
he's guys was just like sticking a fork in the light socket.
Well they had a,
an episode of radio lab about that stuff.
Trend,
you know,
something,
dermal stimulation,
electricity,
they're putting electrodes on certain parts of your brain and it was really
fascinating.
Yeah,
that's definitely a new frontier that could show a lot of promise,
but it's getting more exact,
you know,
like the more you get from this crude version to the exact version,
that's where it's going to start showing promise.
Well,
that's what they were saying on the radio lab thing,
that they have a bunch of people that are essentially hackers that are creating
their own home remedies and they're attaching these things to them and now
sometimes they do it and they lose their sense of smell,
like juicing up weird parts of your brain.
You know,
you see weird things out of the corner of your eyes.
Your feet go numb.
Like you just,
you're,
you're applying electricity to the outside of your head.
But there's been some things where they've shown like significant improvements,
including the ability to focus and the ability to learn tasks.
Like they had this woman go through a sniper training thing.
She did it on the Nache,
she does it,
she's terrible at it.
She knows just like this video game or the hostage situations.
Who Do you shoot and she's missing everybody.
She gets like two out of,
you know,
whatever the fuck the number was.
She does it again.
They strapped these things to her head.
She does the whole 20 minute course.
She,
it,
it's over like like that.
And she goes,
well,
why was it over so quick?
And they go,
that was 20 minutes.
And she goes,
no,
it wasn't.
So they show her the time like this was 20 minutes.
She hits every target 100% accuracy.
And she's like,
what in the actual fuck just happened?
Like they juiced her up with these electrodes and she became a fucking assassin.
Yeah,
that's awesome.
I'm wondering if it was manipulating the brainwave frequency,
like getting her into that Alpha state zone or whether it was,
you know,
prefrontal cortex blood flow or,
there's a lot of different things they can do,
but I think there's a lot of promise in that field.
You know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a shortcut that we're starting to learn.
Well,
we're,
we're still,
you know,
most people at least are still white belts in how to manage the mind,
were amateur race car drivers with this insanely complicated piece of machinery
that most people don't understand the potential of.
And there's different states that you achieve almost accidentally,
right?
You have a couple of shots were at the bar.
You can't,
you're playing pool.
You can't fucking miss.
Everybody's been there.
You know,
you think you're Tom Cruise,
you look away,
you fire the ball dead in the heart of the pocket.
But try recreating that a few,
a few days later and it's gone.
You know,
maybe even an hour from now it's gone.
It's like,
I think that's why the ancients used to blame it on the gods.
The gods are with me.
Hermes was all holding my stick on the pool thing.
Whatever the heck.
Cause it's so crazy.
It's like you don't know when it's gonna come.
It's like you've been gifted by the divine and with the,
with the ancients too.
They only lived to be like 20 so like they had to like figure it out real quick.
It was gods,
the gods have done this for us.
Okay,
I think I have cancer.
See you guys later.
And they'll just fucking probably won't even cancer.
Right.
They're both Brown.
The flu.
Syphilis.
Yeah.
Something that got all the ancients.
Yeah,
it got the VNA,
right.
Well,
who's was the first dude to get vd?
Who's that dirty bastard?
There had to be like the first guy they think.
Right and that's just been around forever.
It just the bane of existence.
But it's funny that there's like a specific disease,
like nobody catches the flu from eating pussy.
You know what I mean?
Like you get like specific diseases from sex sexually transmitted to the Michael
Douglas got that weird one from eating so much box where he got like throat
cancer.
He says he didn't,
he says that it was bullshit.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Yeah,
there was like,
but it coincided with his divorce so I don't,
I'm not sure if I buy it.
He might've been tried to.
Sweet talk goes way back into Catherine Zeta Jones.
What's her name?
That's her name.
The one,
yeah,
that didn't work out.
So they got divorced so maybe it was eating pussy.
If you pull them aside,
I mean come on man.
How much postage eat and oh good Lord.
I'm imagining it's a lot.
I was actually at a dinner party where he was at.
He's the man.
Like he's as far as like having just that natural charisma where you just want
to just pull up a seat and listen to them tell a story.
Could be about him getting a fucking Starbucks.
It didn't really matter when Michael Douglas was telling a story.
It was like,
whoa man.
Including like catastrophic failures as a parent,
you know,
he's got a son that's in jail for drugs that's gotta be like really weird.
You know,
that,
that often happens with those big time movie star fellows and gals.
They become a big time movie stars and they just don't have enough time to raise
her kids.
And then the kids are around.
These weren't really super unhealthy environments and you know,
a lot of like empty pleasure environments and a lack of understanding
discipline.
And then also genetic predisposition to addictions that he had.
And obviously his son Charlie has,
you know,
who knows who other folks in his family might have had as well.
It's a bitter sweet life.
It's challenging.
And I think the way that I look at it is it's,
it's extra pressure.
It's not like it's inevitable that you're going to be fucked up in that
situation,
but it's extra pressure.
And so you have to do extra things to be able to combat that.
You know,
you really have to focus on your discipline,
do things like,
you know,
spiritual journeys and meditation and Psychedelics and things that you've got to
say,
listen,
this is going to be the pressure of the world and this situation is going to try
and steer me this way.
So I got to overcompensate by working that much harder to make sure I stay
grounded and stay balanced.
But those,
you know,
those mechanisms aren't in place and they're not part of mainstream
understanding.
So,
you know,
whereas maybe in 50 years,
a person like Michael Douglas,
it'd be like,
listen,
here's your 18th birthday.
You're going down to Peru.
I know that Sean Man,
really well,
I'll see you in two weeks.
And then every year thereafter you're doing something else,
you know,
staying in,
uh,
an an osram for two weeks or he's got to know that there's so much pressure that
he can help kind of guide this.
But right now it's just nobody knows that much.
Yeah.
Could you imagine if you grew up,
your dad was a giant movie star and you go on the red carpet holding your dad's
hand and like also you have to live in that Guy Shadow.
Yeah.
You know,
like what are you doing man?
Oh,
you run a bakery.
You're Michael Douglas is kid,
right?
Fucking dad's.
Uh,
he won the Oscar.
I don't even know if he won an Oscar.
I'm sure he did.
One of them,
I'm sure.
Something and another.
Yeah.
You know what a fucking weird batch of pressure that is.
You know,
I have friends.
It's debt.
The debt,
their dads are like pretty successful and they still like,
they're adults.
They live under the shadow of their dad.
Even if they're more successful than their dad.
It's like,
see,
you know,
fucking up past your dad know,
it's a weird dynamic.
They call that like the oedipal complex,
right?
Where you have that urge to kill your father and it's not literally kill your
father,
but it means to overcome,
you know,
what his,
what his greatness was,
you know,
be better than him in some way or another and talk your mom and fuck your
mother.
Yeah.
That's another,
I don't even know how to explain that part,
but yeah,
but that's,
that's part of this drive to be better than the generation before you,
which is,
it's why,
you know,
a lot of times,
even in South America,
the Shamans,
they train,
you know,
father to grandson rather than father to son.
They skip a generation to avoid that kind of power dynamic cause they know it's
going to be kind of fucked up if they're both practicing at the same time.
It's always going to be weird.
That's really clever.
Yeah.
That's so clever that they do that.
It was probably out of just sheer necessity,
you know,
I got a way better relationship with my grandfather and every day with my
father.
Right.
My grandfather likes,
there's no pressure on him.
Exactly.
No,
he'd already raised kids.
I was,
as you know,
his daughters kid,
it was easy.
Yeah.
I hung out with that dude,
went fishing with them and shit,
you know,
and he's not wrapped up in the ego of,
that's my boy.
You know,
that's a big problem that fathers get caught up in too.
They identify with their children and that becomes part of their identity.
And then they put so much pressure on these kids to for their own benefit rather
than just,
hey,
you're a human,
you know what's best for you,
buddy.
Yeah.
That's real hard for people,
man.
I've seen that with people trying to dictate their children's careers.
And I had a friend and I grew up who was Korean and Korean families.
I don't know if you don't read Korean friends,
but Korean families are incredibly hardworking,
like incredibly strict,
incredibly disciplined.
Like he was one of the most disciplined people I've ever met.
He was on the national taekwondo team when he was going through his,
uh,
he was going through medical school,
so he was in the middle of medical school and he was also in the national
taekwondo cans.
Like,
well,
fucking do that man.
I mean,
he won the nationals as a fucking medical student.
This guy,
I mean he was studying 16 hours a day and he found time to train.
He would do in between,
uh,
training or in between studying at the library.
He would run stairs at his university.
He would just run the stairs like with this street clothes on.
And that's how he got some of his conditioning in.
Yeah.
I've watched our researcher,
Jared,
as soon as he started medical school,
it's just,
he was practicing Bjj,
he was living in Brazil,
we met him in Brazil.
He's Kinda stout and he's just killing it in there.
And I've seen the circles get deeper and he's losing weight and he still finds a
little time here and there,
but it's a grind.
I imagine that anybody thinks it's the way to do it.
I think everybody's just been doing it like that for so long.
But how has it,
how was it possible that they let doctors work these giant long ass shifts
completely exhausted and take care of people's medical issues and possibly fuck
things up because they're exhausted?
Just because of fatigue.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
and it's kind of like that navy seal type of training that they put you through
enough pressure in medical school or in buds training as,
as it is for the navy seals that they can trust you and battle with people's
lives on the line.
You know?
And I think that's why they make medical school that hard.
You know,
it's like a gauntlet that if you pass this motherfucker,
then you'll be able to handle these long shifts.
Especially,
you know,
when you're interning at a hospital and doing all those,
I think it's probably the right move for seals.
Right.
But for doctors,
I just feel like,
Jesus,
why don't you have more doctors?
You know,
why don't you have extra doctors instead of making one guy work 18 hours a
fucking day.
My friend Steve,
I think you met Steve Graham,
Dr Steve.
He was,
we were,
uh,
when we were friends in Boston.
He was going through his residency and a,
and he was an ophthalmologist and he told me that he was on the toilet taking a
shit with a tray of food in his lap.
He fell asleep and his buzzer went off and that's when he realized like,
like what the fuck am I doing with my life?
Yeah.
He fell asleep on the toilet while he was eating and the Buzzer,
his pager,
it was back when we had pagers.
Doctors.
I think doctors still have page or some of them I think they actually do there.
That's still,
they're the only ones that pager drug dealers and the doctors.
Can you trace people two pagers?
No,
you can't.
There's no fucking payphones anymore.
So if you're a drug dealer and you're trying to do things on the street,
like you have to have a toss guy forgot burners.
You gotta have a burner phone.
How long before they make those drug dealers and adulterers?
I am cricket phones.
All Day.
Yeah.
How many people like by those legitimately,
how many people like buy burner phones and like can I just like,
I like this phone.
This is my fault.
No,
nobody,
no.
Seven,
11 phones.
That doesn't happen.
You know,
one thing about doctors,
people give doctors a hard time,
especially,
you know,
because of this medical crisis that we're in,
but I really don't think it's the doctor's fault.
They're trained to,
you know,
they're trained to follow clinical research,
and they do that really,
really well.
They follow the clinical research.
The problem is,
is that the people funding clinical research have a vested interest.
They're researching products that they want to sell.
They're not researching,
hey,
let's see what happens if we feed this guy a natural diet,
you know,
and do that against placebo.
Well,
that's a couple of hundred grand that nobody's paying for it because nobody's
making any money off that,
you know?
So there's not,
there's an absence of clinical research showing these other kind of functional
medicine and nonprofit ways that people can get healthy.
And I think that really when you're looking at,
you know,
kind of correcting some of the issues in medicine,
that's what needs to happen.
Big nonprofit groups need to get together and start funding clinical trials for
these things that have no profitability,
profitable viability.
You know,
just studying healthy diets,
studying,
you know,
what happens if you float for every day for six weeks studying what happens when
you do all of these other things that you can't possibly make money off of.
And I think that's going to make a big difference.
That is,
and it's also tried talking to a doctor about something that's outside of his
wheelhouse and you know,
you're gonna get a lot of,
you know,
like what do you think about,
you ask a doctor about meditation or Oh yeah,
you know,
that's not going to fucking busy man.
And he's got 18 different patients waiting in his office and that's not as fuel
to study and you can't possibly know everything about the human
body when it comes to every single function of the human body.
All the different mechanisms involves and absorbing nutrients and absorbing like
the,
the different things that can go wrong in various organs.
Like you specialize,
they specialize for reason.
There's a reason why I foot doctors aren't also neurosurgeons.
You know,
you can't be,
and it's,
it's sort of analogous to life.
Like in life,
you can't know everything about everything in life and doctors just most,
you run into a lot of doctors,
you don't want to trade bodies with them.
They go like you're a doctor.
Like you're,
you're a guy who's supposed to be like managing like the health and wellness of
these people that are in your care at least as far as fixing them when shit goes
wrong.
But you've got a pot belly and you don't have an ass like you.
You're,
you're,
you have bad posture,
your,
your necklace kind of slumped forward like in your doctor and you're you,
so you're not on the ball with everything either.
No one is,
it's literally a virtual impossibility to be complete as it,
as far as your education about the entire human body and every single organ and
everything that can go wrong and everything that you could do right to prevent
all these things from going wrong and to really have a deep knowledge in the
benefits of all these different things like yoga and meditation and Super
Healthy,
you know,
nutrient rich diets.
You got to do it.
You have to actually do that.
You have to have a shitty like rich roll who's going to be on the podcast again
soon.
Uh,
I've had him in the past and he's a ultra marathon runner.
He'll became this like fucking health and wellness fanatic and he used to eat
shit food at a terrible diet and then started like juicing beets and eating
healthy vegetables in his whole body was like,
what's going on?
And he looked described like one day where he just got out and just started
running.
Like he had so much energy,
he just started running.
Well,
it takes a guy like that to give you,
I mean obviously it's an anecdotal experience.
It's this one guys take on what happened.
But those,
those stories are super important to say that you know that that is,
if you really do change your diet and throw a bunch of healthy,
like really low fat meats and high,
you know,
like high nutrient vegetables and eat really healthy foods,
you will feel different.
Like you're,
your way,
you interface with the world will feel different.
Yeah.
Eat a lot of Avocados and coconut oil.
Get those healthy fats for your brain and you feel different about it.
It's not gonna fucking aesthetic thing.
It's not like,
oh,
I to look good on the beach when the store myself,
that's not even healthy looking at her.
It's just not even healthy.
Like I saw this photo,
these chicks were bombing on this girl.
It was hilarious because it was a girl who was just thin.
She's just thin.
She didn't look like she was anorexic at all,
but all these women were shitting on her body like,
Oh God,
get her a sandwich.
Oh God.
She's too thin.
Like that's,
she has a thin bones man.
You look at this girl like that's how she's built,
but nobody wants to accept that.
They want to,
they want to think that there's something wrong with this girl.
You're supposed to be overflowing over the top of your fucking jeans.
You're supposed to have like big floppy meat bags in between your legs that
rubbed.
The other one's easier to think that.
Then they go the other way.
She's not healthy.
The best doctor I know is his doctor ingle and we work with them and on it and
so he was trained as a psychiatrist,
clinical forensic child,
psycho psychiatry,
God,
his MD,
and then was like,
ah,
I don't really think this is the whole picture.
So I was just like,
all right,
I'm going to go completely the other way.
Went down to South America and did 40 sessions of Iowasca in 60 nights and did
way too much like,
like fried himself to certain degrees.
So then he had to go live in a tent for a little while to figure some shit out.
He's like,
I was way too much.
So he lived in a tent for an inland for like a year and then he started studying
different kinds of functional medicine.
But he put himself in the lab with all these things.
Sometimes he screwed up,
sometimes he got it right,
but now he's able to combine.
The best part of Western medicine is MD.
The best part of you know,
the shamanistic practices from South America,
the best part of functional medicine and natural medicine and kind of put it all
together.
And that's,
that's where the doctors can become great because maybe they're not specialists,
but the problem with specialists is everything in the body is interconnected and
related.
So if you're only specializing in one thing,
you're going to focus on that potentially to the detriment of the rest of your
body.
So having that at least basic understanding of the connection between all of the
parts of the body is incredibly valuable for a doctor.
And then also putting themselves through all the thing.
How are you going to talk shit on what [inaudible] can do unless you've done it?
You know,
like there's no way to know like what that experience is.
Same with prescribing these drugs.
You know,
it's like you're prescribing drugs that you've never even taken.
Like how are you,
how do you know what this is going to do to somebody?
It's a weird kind of place that we're in right now.
Well,
uh,
I have a friend,
um,
you have some of that fell.
It's good for you.
I have a friend,
um,
who,
uh,
her husband went over to Germany for artificial disc replacement and I'm like,
he's,
he's fucked.
Like his back is fucked.
And so they replaced a bunch of his disks
and he's way better now.
Yeah.
Like way better than I skiing again.
Like because his back was fucked.
And apparently they have these discs in Germany,
these artificial disks that they just can't sell in America.
You just can't sell them.
Nope.
That's not ready yet.
For whatever reason.
It'd be,
maybe there's a good reason.
I mean,
maybe they're,
they're worth more thorough over here and maybe they prevent people from having
to get those old silicon breast implants pulled out.
Like have that kind of shit cops that given you fucking Lupus or some shit.
And that happens.
People get autoimmune disorders because their tits leak.
Yeah.
But these,
these discs,
a Braulio esteem.
I've got one in his neck.
He had a Jujitsu injury and a really bad neck injury where he's temporarily
paralyzed and the whole deal went and got
his disc replaced,
fought,
won the world championships afterwards.
His,
uh,
fighting MMA afterwards.
I mean,
he's gone through this incredibly devastating injury and with an artificial disc
in his neck,
still getting yanked on.
He's still getting choked.
Not that often.
He's pretty fucking good.
He doesn't really get choked very often.
But the point being,
he's got full functionality and so there's this guy,
this guy had discs,
fused in his back,
went to Germany,
they open all that shit up.
Unfused as disks I guess.
I Dunno if they did that and they put these artificial discs in place and now
he's fucking moving around like crazy.
But they canceled.
But I was talking to my doctor about it.
I go,
so why they don't do that in America?
You can't do it in America,
but do you recommend it?
He goes,
I definitely recommend it.
Like they,
if you have the funds,
like if someone that has got a really fucked up back and they have the funds,
he's like,
yeah,
they like it's worth doing.
And it's not like Germany is a free for all and a lot of things.
They're even more strict than us.
I mean,
I,
I'm pretty sure all vitamins or pharmaceuticals pretty much in Germany.
Like we can't sell shit in Germany because like they control everything very
carefully out there.
So,
you know,
describe them though.
At least vitamins.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I mean,
I'm not an expert on that,
but I know the prohibition for us sending anything,
even our vitamin C supplements in there like,
no,
nope,
nope.
That's a pharmaceutical.
Why?
Whoa,
whoa,
that's crazy.
But yeah,
I mean,
well that's what they invented that Regena keen,
which I'm a giant fan of.
You know,
I've had that done several times now.
Man,
you want to talk about something that just cuts your injury like the,
the recovery diet time down radically.
It's very expensive,
but if you have something that's really fucking with you and nagging injury,
oftentimes it just nips that shit in the bud and it's available finally in
America.
But insurance doesn't cover it.
You have to pay for it yourself.
It's like what is the shirts like why doesn't this?
And they like it's off label.
Like what does this mean?
Like I'm not,
I'm not complaining that it's here.
I'm happy that at least you could use it because you still can't do the
artificial discs or any of that other shit,
but it's going to come a point in time where you've got to go.
Is this the most efficient system?
Yeah,
no doubt.
I,
I think really we're at a really cool time where all kinds of new shit is coming
out and it's going to be like the best of what technology can do.
And I think the next big piece is going to become and harnessing what the mind
can do.
And I was doing a little bit of research because I'm doing a lot of writing now.
And there was a study published in 2002 where they took 180 patients and they
gave half of them a fake placebo knee surgery and the other half arthroscopic
knee surgery.
Right.
And,
but everybody thought they were getting real knee surgery.
So it was placebo controlled knee surgery.
Whoa.
And the results were absolutely on par.
The people who got placebo controlled knee surgery,
we're cruising around,
they are walking around fine.
And people who got actual arthroscopic knee surgery,
we're also doing a lot better as well.
Wow.
So I mean,
and that's something that isn't tested very often in surgery cause people don't
think,
how do you do a placebo surgery?
Well they've done,
they've done that with,
there's a study in 1950s that did it with a particular type of heart surgery
where people,
they gave people placebo,
heart surgery in surgery.
The results were on par.
And so I think understanding how much that plays in,
in fact,
because if you go to surgery and you come out and you're all right,
you think you're fixed,
you know like man,
the doctors were in there,
they know shit.
They were cutting shit up there soaking it up.
I'm good.
So that placebo effect,
even in surgery is dramatic.
It's huge.
And I think really the frontiers of medicine are going to be harnessing the
stuff that really does work and had benefit and then us tapping into these late
and resources in our mind and using belief to help speed up and facilitate even
additional healing.
That's amazing.
The other hand,
I really appreciate the fact that there's steps that people have to go through
before they can sell a pharmaceutical drug because we've all been aware of
someone and close to us for something that that had an adverse effect of some
pharmaceutical drug that you see on those late night commercials where you one
of the ones who took Vioxx or Fen Phen Phen Phen God damn sign that fuck
people's hearts up.
Like for life.
Like there's people that have like fucking tricky hearts now because of some
diet pills to lose fat butt and your life.
Yeah,
man.
I know a dude who had a stroke because he was taking Guy Metzger,
UFC fighters,
former champion,
a great fighter.
Great Guy Too.
Really cool.
Can you get it fucking stroke from Vioxx,
Dude,
he,
he's taking the shit for arthritis in his knees and all a sudden he starts
slurring his words and everyone's like,
I'm guy,
something's going on.
And they take them in,
they find out he got a stroke,
you know,
and on top of a lifelong career of a MMA fighting,
he was actually talking about some interesting therapy that he's going through.
Something that's really benefited him,
benefited as bell,
see if he could pull that up.
A Guy Medsker I don't have a laptop in front of me,
but guide Medsker discusses brain trauma video.
It's really interesting,
first of all,
because Guy Metzger who is a pioneer,
I mean I was,
I called one of his fights when I was a early UFC fights in 97 you know,
I've known that guy for a long time.
He's always been like a super stand up,
looks like a movie star,
looks like a hero in a movie.
He's been just a cool dude like always.
And even in this situation it's really cool because he's super honest about how
we,
how we feel.
It's like how he feels physically as opposed to how it used to feel and like
what was going wrong.
And he talked about the improvements that he had.
It's hilarious actually because he talks about the improvements that he has.
Like,
you know,
he's talking about brain trauma from fighting and then a stroke and then later
on he's talking about now he can spar again.
He's firing with some fucking young whipper snapper.
They came into the gym and the doctor's like,
what the fuck are you doing?
He's don't worry,
you didn't hit me.
He's like,
you're in their fucking sparring man.
But for,
you know,
he's a world champion when you're,
when you're a guy like guy masquerade,
like legit striking skills to it.
Really it's fun for him
like being a chess master and being able to play chess
anymore.
Yeah man.
So where he gets his jollies is this it?
Oh No,
I'm still asking you.
Let me see.
Play it in a,
well I'll tell you if it is soft spot.
Yeah,
this is it.
You want to be able to um,
Moran without your cane especially that's with brain injuries.
I don't believe we do enough to be honest.
I think we give a lot of lip service to helping our vets but had a lot of
action.
So that's gurus changing bat.
Well we offer here is a class and then start getting in shape.
It's a different thing.
But this is cool that he's doing that and brain injury at is keep your hands up
son.
We run it through,
he's in Addison,
Texas man class working alongside the carrot brain centers and Irving.
Yeah,
that's for knows what a brain injury does to a person has one too.
I had a 17 year long professional fight career and I had a medicine induced
stroke and I have a brain tumor.
Metzker believes the combat training and then it works for him.
We'll make our military heroes healthier and happier when we've had it attached
to these guys.
Back to that,
that element that made them become,
you know,
soldiers in the first place for Texans with character.
I'm Tracy Cornet.
Yep.
This is a different thing.
See if you could find the other one.
Cause the other one,
he details his therapy that he went through that uh,
helped him.
But that's cool that you could see from that video what kind of a guy he is.
You know?
So what was important was that he was,
um,
he was talking about it in like this really honest way.
Like his bounces off fucked up.
He wasn't trying to shield himself like,
Hey,
I still got it.
Don't worry about that.
Yeah.
You know,
he was,
he was being like real humble and honest about the state that he's in there
making some headway with brain trauma.
It's interesting.
I have some therapies that are effective,
no doubt,
and I think it's going to come from a basket of really curious at this point.
You know everybody,
it's not going to be one magic bullet.
It's going to be a variety of different things that,
yeah,
and stacking these modalities like CBD has some potential hit your nasal
lyposomal.
Glutathione has the potential floating has some potential microdosing siliciden
might apps and potential.
There's been shown some neurogenesis that comes from,
from that,
but all of these things that were,
that are disparate right now.
I think ultimately maybe when put together might be the solution.
Yeah.
That's the solution,
right?
The solution is,
it's not an either or thing.
It's not have you have to go the conventional route with pharmaceutical drugs
and a doctor's prescription or you go the fruitcake route with holistic
medicine.
You're doing yoga and eating fucking Kelp.
It doesn't have to be.
It can be all the good stuff,
all the good stuff,
the good stuff that seems woo woo.
Like,
you know,
you talked to people who do couldn't Daleney Yoga.
Yeah.
Like that's,
I,
I knew this lady.
She's a sweetheart.
I still know her and she's a Kundalini teacher and cheese.
She blazing hot cause a lot of credit.
She was at one point in time,
I mean she's still attractive but she's an older woman.
Right.
But um,
she was beautiful when she was young.
She's beautiful now.
I love her.
She's a good person.
But my point is I don't want to disparage her in any way.
She's so we'll,
we'll,
yeah,
she's so whoa,
whoa.
It's fucking crazy.
Like you can't talk to her,
but anything like she makes you,
like you go onto her property if you go to,
to where her house is,
she makes you like stand in a certain place and say your blessings and,
and,
and like ask for,
ask for the,
the,
uh,
the earth in the woods to embrace you.
I can,
she's not bullshitting man.
She really means that,
you know,
and she,
she will tell you that like Kundalini Yoga and like this practice of yoga is
like changed her being changed who she is as an individual now let's say like,
oh,
she's some woo woo crazy bitch with all due respect with love,
crazy bitch.
I call myself crazy bitch.
But my then my friend Denny got into it and then he proper Co's and Denny,
you know,
Denny Denny,
uh,
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt world champion as a brown belt.
Nogi Jujitsu me,
he's a bad motherfucker and a very good friend and he's not a bullshit artist at
anything.
Nope.
And he started getting deep into Quinn Delaney and he started doing it every day
and he said,
dude,
I'm tripping balls.
He goes,
I'm telling you when I'm in full Kundalini mode because Denny super disciplined
and the type of discipline that you need to be a high level competitive
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt is the same kind of discipline that if applied to
yoga and I like a constant attention and focus on achieving these states.
I now believe that all the stuff that I used to think was horse shit.
I mean,
it's really kind of egotistical that I thought,
I just thought there was too much.
There's so much shenanigans going on.
I mean,
well for whatever reason I would hear people talk about these yoga states where
they would achieve full on DMT realm states and I'd be like,
sure you did.
You know,
it just,
I just didn't believe him.
I thought they were like,
you know how people eat Vegan food always tell you it tastes amazing right there
always.
It's like,
Eh,
it's never like,
it's kind of cardboardy but chicken with the apostrophe tastes just like
chicken.
But you know what I'm saying?
It's like they're overly enthusiastic to the point where their opinion or their,
their taste is not,
it's,
you don't consider it without reservation.
But Danny,
I consider him without reservation.
I know him so well,
so he tells me he's hitting these states.
I was like,
whoa.
Yeah,
I mean the Kundalini Yoga is a,
I think,
well first of all,
the problem that a lot of people have is they stack extra shit on top of the
good stuff.
That's just complete nonsense.
Right?
And that how that makes you want to discard the whole thing.
Like some of this woman's other practices were probably the majority of why you
went,
man,
everything you're doing is whack.
Cause I know some of this is whack and I think that's an issue you make.
But the actual Kundalini Yoga,
I had a podcast with a former navy seal,
this Guy Michael Vega and he was on 11 different pharmaceuticals and,
and that's another big problem in the military as they really overprescribe
psychological meds for these,
these people and the interactions can be a problem.
But she was on 11 couldn't sleep full PTSD,
totally fucked up.
And then his process was exactly the same.
He stopped taking the meds and started doing Kundalini Yoga,
which he stumbled upon and he's actually out here.
And that was the key for him to reverse his PTSD.
And this is an old navy seal,
like a real deal combat that,
you know,
in the shit kind of guy.
And that's the method that worked.
You know,
it kind of makes sense if you think about it because that applies to almost
everything else.
That there's someone out there that does it so well that if you experienced them
doing it,
you go,
oh,
now I get it.
You know what I mean?
Like we've all seen that.
Like I've never taken any music lessons at all,
but I have friends that play guitar and um,
I had a friend that would play classical guitar.
I do flamencos and shit and he would grow his finger narrows long and shit like
the whole deal and held up like put nail Polish over him and he would,
he was my friend from the time we were like 15.
And um,
he would go crazy with this fucking guitar.
You could see his fingers move when he played this crazy flamenco music and you
would realize that it's possible.
But until I had saw him do it like with my fucking fat stupid fingers and like I
don't,
I guess you could get there,
but I never seen anybody get there.
You know,
you've got to see it.
And it's the same with martial arts.
I remember being a kid like watching like black belts for the first time,
watching people throw kicks and watching people like this guy's pacifically,
this Guy John Lee and watched him.
I remember watching him hit the bag and now knowing that that was possible,
whether that was in my mind,
it would those the what he was doing though,
the amount of power that he had and the speed that he had and the execution,
the perfect technique didn't exist in my head.
There was no,
there was no model for it,
you know?
So the,
to watch someone do it in the flesh was all a sudden I was like,
Whoa,
this is a real thing.
Like this is possible.
You can achieve that level.
Whereas you take the average person and tell them to go kick something,
it's going to look ridiculous.
But this guy had it all polished down to this tornado move.
Why Am Wham?
And he just,
he just had the motions down and it was fascinating to watch.
And so because of that,
like I aspire to achieve a similar level proficiency that this guy had.
There was like,
my goal is to get as good as John Lee.
And so when you look at coon Daleney Yoga,
it's gotta be the same thing.
It's gotta be any it with every discipline there's,
you get better at it.
Every time I do yoga,
I get a little bit better at it.
Every time I hit poses I get a little better.
I can go into it deeper.
I,
my body is more comfortable there.
I just,
I set into it better.
My balance is better.
And you got to think that I'm not doing it that often.
You've got to think these motherfuckers that are doing it every day,
they're getting to these crazy places.
And I'm not doing Kundalini Yoga.
I'm doing just like just stretching and all that kind of,
I don't know what you would even call it like with the discipline is,
but the coon Delaney is specifically designed according to Denny to try to
stimulate these psychedelic states and what they're using is breath and you
know,
you can get that in a variety of different ways.
And the other thing that I've done,
it's called holotropic breathing,
which is pretty much like Kundalini yoga without the yoga aspect.
And Kundalini Yoga has very little to do with stretching.
It's mostly getting in postures and breathing really,
you know,
deep breaths frequently and kind of draw it visualizing
and some visualization,
visualizing,
drawing energy up from your Kundalini Center,
which is the base of your body.
And then doing these Breathworks.
And I've felt what,
what can happen when you're in these,
you know,
hyper oxygenated states and it's really,
really powerful.
I haven't done the Kundalini Yoga and like a proper session.
I've just done it a little bit where you kind of bounce up and down and you're
breathing getting these things,
but it's accessing that same mechanism,
which is basically flooding your body with oxygen and creating these seemingly
psychedelic states.
Yeah,
seemingly mommy and they are psychedelic.
I mean,
I would like to see some studies done on what's going on when you're doing that
holotropic breathing,
like if you hit like a peak,
if they could put those EFM g of the key functional Fmri,
Fmri,
if they could put that on you.
All the various ways they have a monitoring.
What the fuck's going on in your dome?
If they could do that while you were in that,
like if you got to that psychedelic state and he told them I was there,
I was there,
and they're like,
okay,
well let's,
let's look at the chart and see.
Yeah,
I mean death.
They'd probably see it in a lot of things.
They'd see it in blood flow,
they'd see it in brainwave activity,
they'd see it and in a variety of things.
I want to know what happens when you're killing on stage.
I want to know what that is.
I bet it,
I bet it's in that 10 Hertz Alpha frequency.
That would be probably exactly where you want to be for that creative.
Everything's easy.
It's smooth.
You lose track of time.
I mean that's the characteristic of that 10 hertz kind of window,
that sweet spot,
that flow state.
If there's a weird state you hit.
Yeah.
So weird state you hit when everything's cracking and I love watching other
people kill too cause I could kind of see them in that state.
I'm like well you know like you watch like Joey Diaz is like one of the best
examples because Joey will reach these these states and he'll say things off the
top of his fucking head that you would swear somebody like somebody would like
we'll do with Labor for years to try to come up with a line as beautiful and
poetic and he'll say it and then after it comes out of his mouth he starts
laughing because he's laughing at it because he didn't even know he was going to
say it.
And you realize like,
that guy's gone.
He's gone.
He's in that and he's addicted to it.
He said it's totally addicted to killing.
That's funny you say that because I talk with Steven Kotler wrote this book,
the rise of Superman,
and they've done a lot of studies on these flow states and when you're in this
flow state,
you're releasing a concoction of five different indogenous drugs,
and I can't name them off the top of my head,
but he makes the argument that flow state is by far the most addictive substance
in the world because you're getting dopamine,
norepinephrine,
all of these different indogenous drugs,
basically,
they get flooded through your body and nothing feels better.
I mean,
you can chase a high every other which way,
but once you felt that you're going to want to get back to that more and more.
I mean,
it's incredibly addictive,
incredibly productive,
but also addictive.
Yeah.
Any guy that's ever done anything dangerous who talked to BMX folks or
skateboarders or any of those extreme maniacs,
those guys for sure are a ditto.
Ditto that experience the rush of danger and pulling it off.
Fuck,
you know,
you see those guys,
they do a flip and then they land in like fuck yeah,
it's like the university is charging them like Highlander and shit.
Like a lightning bolts going through them.
If you'd watch chocolate and chocolate Dellwood when he's the best example of
that state because he would win and he would throw his arms back in,
roar and yell with his chest,
poked out,
pull up,
pull up a video of chocolate,
Dell celebrating.
There's like a,
there's compilations of him celebrating when he was in his prime.
Dude,
you want to talk about like if you wanted the guy to recruit new fans,
if you said,
man,
what is this MMA thing?
Watch this motherfucker.
What is this the most bad ass celebration?
What does this is like an edited version?
Yeah.
Find one where they didn't do their own dance mix to it.
Just show it man.
If you could show it,
you could know and hardly anybody ever going to feel that.
That same thing.
We can all taste it and then our own certain little ways.
But if you could bottle that feeling,
forget about it,
and everybody would just hit that button as many times as possible.
You can't.
You can't and you,
you,
you don't deserve it.
You don't deserve it.
You need to do what he did to get there.
You have to fight Bob Aloosa brawl,
Tito Ortiz,
you gotta fight Kevin Randleman.
You've got to fight all those fucking guys.
You've got to fight rampage Jackson.
You got to fight ouster over him.
You gotta fight those guys.
If you don't fight those guys,
you don't have,
you don't deserve that feeling like he's in there with murderers and he's
throwing haymakers and when he was at his best dude,
God damn,
he was a ferocious motherfucker.
You know his style almost like it kind of did him in because he was so
aggressive and he was so willing to take one to give one.
He wanted to get you into a war of wills.
He was like,
dude,
there's no way.
There's no,
you just did.
You don't understand.
There's no way you're going to hit me and it's not going to hurt and I'm going
to fucking kill you if you stand in front of me.
I'm gonna Smash your face in.
And that was like his style.
Skillful of course.
I mean he did have do good defensive skills,
but he would oftentimes abandoned them just with just rage and just go after
opponents.
So like if you wanted like the perfect guy to like if you wanted to show
somebody,
I want you to watch MMA,
watch a chocolate Dell fight in his prime,
you'd be like fucking Christ man.
Like when he beats up Tito Ortiz and he has him up against the cage is just
fucking unloading these combinations and Tito starts to slump down fucking
Christ man.
I mean Jesus Christ,
that guy was a fucking warrior in there and Rah Rah over those feelings cause
his arms back.
You appreciate it.
It's not like a guy who just decision to guy to death.
He blanketed on top of them through little baby punches.
Now,
this is a guy just threw his soul,
let a guy came out,
triumph,
and he's like,
you don't get that roar if you barely win by a split decision and a fight where
you didn't take any chances where you,
you know,
you did the right thing,
but you stifled them up against the cage and put it on the ground and got on top
of them and it didn't really make any risks.
No,
you only get that when you go balls out barbarian style.
Yeah.
Ah,
look at that picture.
No video.
And it seems like contact no video of this zoo,
Fhfa,
how dare you zoo for my employers,
employers contact sports.
There's some of the best ways to get that.
I mean,
you'll see that also when like a running back runs over three different giant
men who've been training their whole life to bring them down.
They get in there and you'll get a tight tastes that probably none quite the
same as chuck Ladell,
but something about these contact sports where you're actually just in it and
just getting pounded by different other individuals and then triumphing releases
that massive feeling.
Yeah.
You know,
I never experienced that.
I never like any tournament that I won or anything like that.
I always felt weird after it was over.
I never felt,
I felt relief because it was over and now I can relax.
I did feel good about it later when I thought about like,
yeah,
I fucking won.
Wow,
I have the trophy.
I could look at it like this is mine.
I won this.
But when it was over like the state of mind,
even if I won by knock,
especially even if I won by knock out because then I will always,
I was always like,
fuck,
that could have been me.
Like I'm not even making any money doing this.
I'm out here at throwing kicks it people and they're kicking me and I'm kicking
them and look what happened.
This fucking kid,
I didn't even know this kid.
I just don't even know this kid and I just put them in the hospital like this is
ridiculous.
That's what I would think.
I would never be like,
that's why I had to quit that shit.
Yeah,
there's something missing.
I was too.
I was also too aware of the potential downsides,
right?
Like I was a early on adaptor of head trauma paranoia because I'm pretty honest
about,
I think one of the things about being a martial artist,
at least for me,
the way,
uh,
I got better at it quicker is that it was super honest about all the shit that I
did wrong.
I never tried to pretend anything was better than what it was.
I would look at everything and I'd never be satisfied.
All the techniques I like,
that's not crisp enough.
There's not,
the weight transfers on hard enough.
There's like whatever it was,
I'd be like,
I got to just keep drilling this over and over and over again.
And because of that,
it was like acutely aware of my performance levels,
which is why when I started getting hit in the head a lot,
I started looking at the performance of my thinking and I was like,
something's off.
There's something going on here.
Like I'm feeling a very small and I'm not trying to attribute it to fatigue.
Like maybe it's cause of fatigue.
Maybe it's because I'm tired because I've been training a lot cause some
fighting.
And then I was like,
maybe I'm getting hit in the head too much.
And I was like,
Whoa,
fuck man,
this is,
and then I started thinking about these people that you see in life.
Like you've run into some old and he's hunched over and he's got a cane.
You don't think of that guy as being a three year old running in his dad's
backyard,
laughing and giggling and impervious to injury and flopping down on his butt and
just getting right back up.
Cause he's only three inches off the ground.
Now you look at a decaying creature who's reached the,
the,
the final slide of his existence in this dimension he's at,
he's on the way out.
You don't see the full journey.
And I think we think of these guys that you run into in the gym that are punchy
and you think of them and you go,
oh that fucking guy,
man.
Yeah,
he's punched drunk.
That guy didn't use to be punched drunk though.
He used to be a regular guy.
He used to be a regular guy that you can talk to and now he's in this weird
place.
And I know I didn't,
you know,
I didn't compete that long.
Especially like with a lot of head blows,
like the,
the I way more head blows in boxing and kickboxing,
which all happened in the last like two or three years that I was doing martial
arts,
like really intensely and competing.
So I don't think I took too much.
But when I,
when I think about people that I know that I know are fucked up map now that
that bothers me,
man.
It's one of the main things that bothers me about this.
No,
no.
And,
and it's,
you know,
it's interesting,
it's like choosing this lifestyle that you know,
can give you access to these feelings.
Like maybe Chuck Mendell felt that 0.0,
zero,
1% of the whole world will ever feel you get access to a little piece of that.
But it comes at a terrible price.
You know,
if you stick with it too,
if you stick
where the two long,
and that's the problem is what we were talking about earlier is the addiction,
the addiction to that fucking rush rush,
that wild feeling.
I know,
like I said,
I've never felt it.
Well you look at some of the people who are really intriguing me right now and,
and they have a different kind of attitude when they're in there.
Sometimes they can feel it.
Like someone like John Jones for example,
is a,
is a good example of that where it's just so calculated calm and flow,
you know,
everything looks like it's,
you don't see that rage come out of him in the cage anymore.
And so he's so efficient at making great guys look silly.
And then,
and even Connor,
even though he's just starting out and he's got a lot of tough for guys to
fight,
he has a little bit of that,
that element too where everything just looks easy for him in there.
And I think that's the next wave because,
and they're going to,
they're going to deny themselves maybe some of the pleasure on the other side,
but their performance in that level in that mode is going to be pretty fucking
tough to beat.
Yeah,
it's very interesting seeing these various styles that are emerging.
You know,
one of the things that I really love about the UFC,
um,
I,
and this is,
uh,
as a person who's seen it from the really early days,
you know,
I started watching UFC too.
So,
and being able to call more than a thousand fights live from just a few feet
away.
You're seeing,
it's like a mathematical equation you're seeing,
like what are the benefits of being 265 pounds of built like Brock Lesnar versus
what are the benefits,
a superior gas tank
like Cain Velasquez and really good wrestling skills.
What are the benefits of crisp technique over whether the benefits of rage and
aggression and muscle.
What are the benefits of,
of of a pace that no one can keep up with versus a guy who throws knockout blows
but gets tired after the second round?
Like where,
where's the numbers?
What Ciena?
I'm looking at it not just as like individuals with unique personalities,
unique physical skills like we all know like guys like Hector Lombard,
like look at him.
That's a unique physical specimen period.
There's no denying that.
You just can't deny it.
He's just does not a,
that's not a regular dude.
He doesn't move like a regular dude.
He's not going to hit you like a regular dude.
So there's a massive benefit.
His goal somehow has muscles that attach to his trap and even though I didn't
even know that's possible.
So stupid strong too.
Dude,
you watch him fight.
Tim Boetsch.
Tim Bosch is a like a really big one,
85 and Timbo shit strong as fuck dude.
And Tim Bush would go to take down and Hector snapped him down and sprawled like
I have never seen a five foot eight man due to a big fucking viking looking dude
like Timbo.
She just grabs him and snaps some down.
It's like fucking Christ.
How strong is that dude?
Like he's like the way through Jake shields around.
Who the fuck has ever done that before?
Who's ever done that before?
He,
he flipped Jake shields through the air and hip tossed him.
Jake shields is a worldclass Brazilian jujitsu black belt.
Like he competed against Marcello Garcia,
Cameron Earl.
I mean he was,
he was in the mix against John Fitch.
He,
he,
he grappled against like some really top level competition and perform very well
in,
in straight Jujitsu.
So to watch him just get fucking thrown through the air with the greatest of
ease here.
Like what kind of a freak is that?
But is that the way to go or is the way to go to p that guy and also pretend
you're not there to fight?
Like you're a regular dude to fight.
Like you're a guy who doesn't have ridiculous explosive power,
but always have that on tap and know when to release a little bit out of it and
then pull it back a little bit on them.
That way you can get that Frankie Edgar Pace.
Well,
it's not only a proving grounds for strategy like you're talking,
which is amazing,
but it's also a proven ground for mental conditioning.
I mean this is the place where there's absolutely zero room to be at less than
your potential.
And you see that all the time.
You see fighters come out and for whatever reason,
you know that a different operating system in that body would be fighting that
night better.
So for whatever reason they weren't reaching it.
And then you see the converse side like Tj Dillashaw versus Barao when he came
out where you know he's on that bleeding edge of 99 nine nine of his potential
of what he can do at that given point and the states that they get in to get
themselves that way.
The practices,
Jon Jones,
when we actually ran into him before his last fight at dinner and he was talking
about a really interesting practice that he was doing in which he was going
through all of the worst case scenarios that can happen against Daniel Cormay.
Daniel Cormay taking him down,
all of the worst.
And he said,
and I've accepted those and I'm fine with him.
And for him that was releasing any fear that he had of what might happen in the
ring.
And that's what an Danieli Billy pointed this out.
That's also what the Sam or I would do before battle.
And this is described vividly in the Hagia query,
the book of the Samurai.
They would vividly you imagine in their mind all of the different ways they
could die,
gutted in eviscerated their guts spilling out in their hands and Arrow piercing
their neck.
They would go through all of these different scenarios in their head,
be at peace with them,
understanding that death was coming to them all anyways.
And then that way they wouldn't fear these scenarios.
So they were fierce are in battle.
So these techniques that are getting re innovated by people like John Jones are
really,
you know,
amazing to see because a lot of times innovation comes out of necessity and
there's no greater necessity than another killer trying to pummel you in front
of millions of people.
Yeah.
The people want to say that it's 99% mental or 90% mental.
That's not really true because no matter how strong your brain is,
John,
John's gonna kick your fucking ass.
Okay,
chuck can be drunk on coke.
He's going to bitch slap you.
He's a better athlete.
He's just better fighter period.
But if John Jones,
his mind is totally on point,
if he's in that Samurais zone,
that is an unbelievably deadly combination.
When you have the superior athlete with the superior mental toughness,
like a guy who goes through a really strong amateur wrestling background house,
like all those guys have some savage mental toughness and you add that to like
some sort of meditation practice or some sort of,
a lot of them are using hypnosis now,
which is really interesting.
There's a guy who a Joe Schilling was talking about,
I'll say his name because it's on my,
it's on my Twitter thing,
but,
uh,
I want to,
he just did Ian Mccall as well.
He's hypnotizing motherfuckers and he's doing it through facetime.
He's hypnotizing them.
Vinny.
God dammit.
Why can't I remember his last name?
Shoreman I believe it is.
Yes.
Vinny shoreman that's it.
And Vinny shoreman is also an excellent striking commentator.
He does like a lot of kickboxing events and,
um,
Moy Tai events and he works with some of these fighters in hypnotizes them and
puts them in the states of mind.
[inaudible] essentially,
I want to talk to them about doing it for standup comedy because I don't think
anybody's ever done it for like,
I don't think anybody's ever been hypnotized.
Like,
especially where everything's going well.
Yeah,
no,
I can sit,
see what happens.
Let's see what,
what happens if I get this guy to read my fucking brain?
Well,
all of these things are,
and we've talked about it a bit on this podcast already.
They're manipulating the belief system.
And I've,
you know,
talked about knee surgery,
placebos,
this placebo,
there's no CBO affect the power that the brain has to be able to affect
conditions within the human body.
And then so manipulating that to your benefit,
I think is,
is a huge part of,
you know,
the next frontier.
And I also think,
especially when there's two people involved,
if we understand that the belief system has a lot to do with potential outcomes,
both for health and a variety of things,
that's all been proven.
You know,
belief has huge,
you know,
a huge amount of leverage on what you're capable of doing physically.
So understanding that,
then it would make sense that evolutionarily speaking,
humans would be good belief detectors of each other,
right?
Because that would allow you to assess whether your opponent at a certain point
or someone you were going to fight might be able to beat you or a mate that you
were going to be with was going to be good,
or someone was going to be able to provide,
or your friend was going to be,
you know,
worthwhile.
So detecting belief had to be a skill that we've developed.
And I think we're very good at that.
We know when someone inherently is confident or whether they're cocky and
insecure,
hiding something,
you know?
So our belief detection is really good.
And I think so it's double.
And when you'd look at these competitors,
because not only is their belief strong,
but the other person across from them can detect that belief to a certain
degree.
And then that might start to shake their belief.
If they're like,
man,
this motherfucker for sure believes he's going to kick my ass.
Is My belief enough to believe that that's not going to happen?
You know?
So it's this kind of contest of,
of course,
both physically,
but I think people are kind of measuring each other.
And I think that's an advantage that like again,
Conor McGregor has,
I really believe that he believes that he is going to kick that other person's
ass.
So the other person,
when they're dealing with them,
they're like,
man,
this motherfucker really believes this.
You know?
Am I sure?
Am I sure that I'm going to win?
And then that starts to cause doubt and that doubt creates this negative
cascade.
Yeah.
Isn't it fascinating how that works at the,
the other person can kind of somehow or another sense your true state.
Yeah.
Somehow or another you can put on the face of the confident person,
but they can go,
this is one of the fuckers buffet,
right?
I smelled bluffing.
He's shaky.
There's something going on.
Yeah.
You know,
I feel that with audiences,
audiences know when your head's not there or when you're not,
right.
You could say the exact right words and the exact right order with the exact
right amount of pauses,
but if your intent isn't there,
if your mind isn't there,
it's like they don't,
they don't connect with it.
It's a form of hypnosis.
I really think that standup is some form of hypnosis.
Yeah.
So they're their belief detectors rack.
If you don't really believe that you're in the pocket and you're,
and you're delivering it the right way,
they'll,
they'll kind of,
they'll kind of sense that.
And that's what I'm kind of trying it too.
And then the opposite of that is,
is fear because fear is a belief of some probability that some shit bad shit is
going to happen.
You know?
So it's almost like a negative belief mechanism.
Of course there's danger and having,
you know,
danger is real.
But the fear that's on top of that danger,
you know,
that is a somewhat of a belief that some other bad shit is going to happen.
And that's why it manifests is because it is a belief.
It is a belief that something's gonna happen.
If you're afraid on stage that you're going to bomb,
you know,
that fear will start to wind its way into yourself and you'll create that
because some part of you believes that's when,
uh,
that's what's going to happen.
So it's almost like fear is the no CBO of regular,
everyday
living,
whereas belief is the placebo of everyday living.
That's why it's so devastating when you think about people that you don't talk
about being bullied like some,
some kids have gone through.
I've gone through like really horrific bullying episodes as children.
And that those when,
when you think about what's happening,
when you're getting bullied or you know you're scared of someone in your
neighborhood or you know there's someone who's harassing you or stalking you,
they become,
it's almost like they become a virus in your mind where someone,
like if you're in school and you have to get on that fucking boss and go and
this big fuckers going to smack you in the head every day,
every and you're going to be living in fear of this guy trying to figure out
where he is.
That guy becomes like a virus in your head.
And when you think of how meditation works,
how meditation is sort of resetting you and clearing all of the programs that
are in there,
clearing all the things that seem to be externally dictating behavior.
When you're,
when you're,
when you're fighting,
especially when you're competing and someone's beating you at something,
especially if they're talking shit,
they're kind of hypnotizing you totally because they're,
they're planting their mind or their personality is a virus in your head and
then all sudden you are dealing with them.
Like they're physically coming into your head and fucking with your head where
you're not physically getting in their head at all.
They just scored on you.
You know,
they're,
they're kicking your ass,
they just leg kicked you and they're like,
what?
Bitch?
And they pop you with a jab.
He like,
fuck.
Like you're not,
you know,
you're not in his head at all.
No.
He's fucking,
your belief is getting stronger while yours is getting weaker.
Yes.
Like you are getting hypnotized as you're getting fucked up.
Yeah.
That's fascinating.
When you think about that,
and it happens not only in the cage,
but beforehand,
you know,
you see those people who've gotten him in someone else's head way early.
I wonder if this can be compared in some ways to the sense of loss we feel after
relationships because with some people there's a,
a deep anger after relationships.
Uh,
and people break up because not only do they feel this sense of loss,
but they feel like you took something from them.
Like you took like a happiness.
He took some of that you took because they kind of become a part of you.
You kind of link up with each other in some sort of weird way that's gotta be
similar to hypnosis in a way too.
And that what's going on with all these things is the mind is far more malleable
than we ever give it credit for being the personality is far more dependent upon
Wim and circumstance and influence than we ever really want it to be.
All these things are kind of playing out at the same time.
There's not any one thing like,
so these,
these rigid structures that we think of as this is,
well,
his personality is like this.
Well,
he was totally different.
Once you get hooked up with her,
of course that bitch bewitched him.
She hypnotized him.
But did you
know she like women can do,
some women can do that to men and some men can do that to women.
They fucking turn them into a different person.
It's like they be,
which you would their personality,
you're getting sleepy,
sleepy.
This dick is only for me.
You know,
like people do shit like that to each other.
You know?
And I think those,
this,
these connections of the mind are these like poorly understood interfaces that
we have with each other at these poorly understood connections.
And that we want to,
we want to just like,
sometimes we can't handle it when to just get distance from all being one.
Just give me,
get some distance.
I have to take time off,
man.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna go on a vacation.
How other people are influencing your sphere with relationships?
I think it has a lot to do with attachment and identity.
You know,
you get with someone and that becomes part of your identity.
I'm so and so's husband.
I'm so and so's boyfriend.
She's my girlfriend,
my girlfriend.
You know,
it becomes this part part of you,
your your ego,
your sense of identity,
and you get attached to that because it's feeding you with something that you
think you need some validation.
Maybe she's super hot and that helps you feel it's a,
it's like a tricky little trap that helps you feel like,
man,
I'm the man,
my girl is super hot,
you know,
so that part's inside you.
And then she leaves and you're like,
shit,
maybe I'm not the man because that's what was feeding you.
But the key to that is you got to get to a state of almost invincibility
yourself,
where you don't need anything from anybody or anything you can do.
You're just free to enjoy it.
That's just extra on top of it.
You know,
you don't,
you're not borrowing anything from them to make up your identity.
You're just enjoying the shit out of him and adding more,
piling it on top.
So when they leave,
you're not really at a loss of anything.
It's just all right.
I don't get to experience that extra good thing anymore.
Yeah.
Most people don't see it that way because they watched John Cusack movies and
they want to stand outside of chicks fucking house with a boom box playing some
song that used to listen to before you bang you.
Have you heard that country song?
It's called redneck crazy.
It's like the most,
it's like the most absurd song ever.
It's like,
I'm going to park outside of your window and shine my lights through your park
outside of your house.
Shaima lights through your window.
Throw beer cans at your shadow.
You know you broke the wrong heart baby.
You'd made me redneck crazy.
Oh.
And it's like playing on and you'll just hear people humming along and singing.
I mean,
it's amazing.
Jamie,
do you want to please don't,
let's pretend we didn't bring it up.
It's unbelievable to hear cause it's just patterning this crazy behavior that
people have of this possession.
That's my girl and the fact that she's enjoying her life with someone else.
I think the song even says,
did you think I was going to wish you well?
I'm not that kind of man baby,
or something like that.
Oh crap.
You know,
it's like,
Whoa,
but that's a worm that's in our consciousness that we're supposed to feel like,
you know,
you took something from me.
How dare you?
I hope you're never happy again.
But how about the balls to make a funk and songs and you're talking about
harassing someone's daughter know because she doesn't want to fuck you anymore.
Maybe that,
look at that behavior and wonder why your personality sucks.
Your personality sucks.
That's why she left in the first place.
You asshole.
Throw a beer.
Can their fucking house.
How can you grow up baby baby's exactly the word cause it's seems so needy.
He needed what she was going to provide him because if she stuck with him
forever,
right?
She's stuck.
She can't do any better.
She wants to improve her life.
You're just drinking beer and hanging out by the lake.
Fuck you,
dude.
You know what is this?
Here's the lyrics.
Wish I knew how long it's been going on.
Oh,
she cheated on him.
How long you been getting some on the side?
Well,
a little different.
Uh,
Nah.
He can't amount to much by the look of that little truck.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
He can't amount to much because he has a small vehicle.
Well,
he won't be getting any sleep tonight.
Oh Great.
Okay.
I'm going to lean my headlights in your bedroom windows through empty beer cans
at both your shadows.
I didn't come here to start a fight,
but I'm up for anything tonight.
Okay,
but you didn't come to certify it,
right?
What do you think's gonna Happen?
You mocked his truck.
Okay,
asshole.
You threw beer cans.
You have a,
you have a fucking spotlight.
They use to poach dear.
Putting it through his window.
You know you broke the wrong heart baby and drove a redneck crazy redneck.
Crazy.
Do you think I'd wish you the best?
Endless love and happiness.
You know,
that's just not the kind of man I am.
Yeah.
I'm the kind that shows up at your house at 3:00 AM.
Oh my God.
I'm going to lean my head lights into your bedroom windows there as both the low
blow redneck,
crazy redneck crazy forest fuck.
But that,
I mean,
and people,
it's playing on pop radio because it strikes a chord and I think some girls
think,
man,
he really was inter,
you know,
he,
he really loved her because look at what he's doing on the other side and that's
just the,
that's just a tricky little trap that we got to transcend,
you know,
least of my concerns,
my concerns is that there'll be guys that listened to it and think it's okay to
act like that if a girl is so silly that she thinks all that,
he just loves him.
That's why he's all doing that.
Shooting up the house.
Shit.
You think he really wants a sheet up his fucking house,
which is letting her know he loves or there's,
there's women who grow up like that.
They all fucking black eye and they're having this conversation to their kid
with a Marlboro hanging out of their mouth less and sugar.
Your Dad and I have very passionate relationship and I pushed his buttons and
you know,
and he loves me and if he didn't love me he wouldn't fucking hit me.
And I don't want to all make sense to you right now,
but someday it will.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's this old paradigm that is in dire need of transcendence and the need is
basically,
you know,
we have to be fully full.
I think Don Miguel Ruiz mix the example of,
you know,
create enough self love enough self satisfaction and enough inside yourself that
you don't need anything from anybody else.
Your kitchen is fully stocked so you're not starving.
You know a lot of people,
you stock your own kitchen with your own self fulfillment and then you don't
need to eat any little burger that comes on the side of the road or some hot dog
from a stand you can get because you're starving.
You got plenty to eat.
And that's,
I think the analogy that we need to have.
We need to be full and whole and we needed to have standards as human beings we
accept of ourselves.
Like what you shouldn't accept from yourself.
Don't accept from yourself that you're the guy that's going to be outside
someone's house at three o'clock in the morning shining head light to their
fucking windows and throwing beer cans.
Don't accept that you're that guy.
You're not that.
He can't be that guy.
If you're that guy,
no one's going to come to you for advice.
No one's going to take you seriously.
You're,
you're a fucking dumb ass.
You're a dumb ass child who gives him to every whim.
It's like someone who comes after one stroke every time.
I can't help it.
Like you're a baby.
You're a fucking baby.
You learn some God damn discipline.
Yeah,
it sucks.
Yeah.
You feel lonely.
You get depressed.
God,
Tinder stupid.
Find some more checks.
They're everywhere.
People want to fuck.
They love it.
That's why there's so many of us.
What are you doing,
man?
You tell me,
you get this one chick,
you can't get another check.
Go get another one.
Stupid and he will too.
That's the thing,
to not have any friends and not have any friends,
anybody who talks you through it,
and he goes,
dude,
come on.
Let's go.
So what people get so goddamn connected when they date,
they get so fucking connected that they feel like you stole something from Him
who been getting some pleasure from another entity.
I ain't tolerating it.
Ah,
sent us bust up your sleep patterns.
I'm going to fuck with your Beta waves.
So I'm going to kick your fucking Ram sleep right and the deck.
You fuck with me?
You fuck with mass sleep?
I'm the cop of family and fucks with your sleep bank.
That's what he's doing.
He a fucking baby.
My four year old and my six year old,
we're having an argument today.
Um,
because uh,
my six year old was letting the four year old right on her paper for a while,
but then she's like right on your own paper and she wrote a little bit more.
That's just like I said it in your own paper that she wrote on her paper and she
tried to write and hurt and they were going back and forth writing on each
other's papers.
Like,
Whoa,
settle the fuck down.
Stop trying to hurt each other.
This is not,
this is not,
hey,
do it this.
Okay,
just this.
We've got to learn how to communicate here,
but that foreign sex,
they're not a fucking 30 year old man with a pig truck.
Big Old jacked up check.
Yeah,
little truck.
He ain't got shit in a man kind of little ass.
Fucking truck came from another country too.
Goddamn.
Drop it.
I told you what a truck,
what do you want?
Reliability.
Yeah.
That's the process of growing up.
It should be learning to transcend those initial feelings like yeah,
that's,
that's of course reasonable when you're four and six were little monkeys in this
crazy world where sorting shit out,
but then as you get more practice at that,
that should become more and more absurd with every passing year if we just
committed to that.
Committed to not going after people and fucking with people's lives,
like showing up at someone's house three o'clock in the morning and shining your
headlights and just commit to never going.
They're never doing that kind of shit.
I'd never showing up at someone's house and starting a fight.
Never.
It was just all that put all that aside,
the world,
we'll get like 90% better.
Like instantly.
If everyone had a standard of behavior like I could,
we kind of trust that you know,
people in this town,
they don't fight you just,
you talk things out.
Most dudes in this town of rational,
imagine if you've got a talent like that,
you're like,
Whoa,
where is this place?
Oh,
it's just a straight outside of Seattle.
This one town.
Like everyone's cool.
Like what?
That might be comes Colorado.
But could you imagine?
It might be,
it might be like spreading out of Denver right now,
like the epicenter of the fucking cannabis nucleus.
It is possible,
right?
If you could get a group of friends like we have,
we have a group of like 15 dudes that I would give 1 million bucks,
two in a bag and never counted if they gave it back to me because they're like
15 of us.
But for most people it's hard to find fucking people like that.
But yeah,
a town,
if you had a town of 100 percenters,
hundred percent down,
100% all you know,
just you could count on them for everything.
They are who they are.
God Damn,
what a great town that would be.
You would know,
would never get in fistfights.
Yeah,
and I think that's a big key of how to improve our situation is maybe we won't
be able to get the whole town,
but we can start a queue getting these tribes around us.
Like you're saying,
you have these 15 people.
Yeah,
they don't all live together,
but through travel and through talking,
you end up interacting with all these people anyway,
so it kind of insulates you.
You have your own tribe of these people that we trust impeccably and they can
help improve our lives and I think that's a major part that's missing.
We're missing that sense of tribe where we would give absolutely anything.
It's not like,
oh,
could I stay in your guest bedroom?
Fucking of course you could stay in my guest bedroom.
Like what?
I don't even ask that silly question.
You could do anything that is mine is yours.
That feeling that's innate to us.
I think we're going to have to start trying to get that back because I think we
need that.
I mean that's the kind of creature that we are.
Yeah,
I agree.
And I think that,
you know,
you know how you ride a favor.
Has it hooked up or,
yeah,
he owns like a block.
Yeah,
he has like a bunch of,
he's so smart.
But dude,
it's just so clever and a bunch of different ways.
Very good businessman.
Very clever.
And you know how he set himself up outside of the UFC as a bunch of houses.
He flips and stuff and he's got,
he's always got something going on,
owns real estate,
but him and all these alpha male guys,
the,
that's their team team,
Alpha Male,
a,
uh,
one of the top level,
a high level,
uh,
gyms in the country,
particularly for the lighter weight classes.
Like they have 135 pound champion,
Tj Dillashaw,
and they're just a wealth of like real good talent in there,
including guys you haven't even heard of yet that you will hear of soon.
But the point being is that he's got it set up where he can kind of do whatever
the fuck he wants.
You know,
he has it set up where he's got,
you know,
he's got the housing business,
he's got the gym,
he runs,
he's got all these different things going on at the same time.
That's a,
that's a pretty sweet place to be in.
Of course.
Well he's got his tribe that actually lives right near him,
which is obviously the best case scenario.
Yeah.
They're all having on one street.
Houses
that they all own.
They just bought houses next to each other.
That's so clever.
Absolutely.
And I think he does that.
Everybody says they want to do that,
but nobody does.
Nobody does.
And it's probably the single thing that would improve people's quality of life
way more than the neighborhood or whatever other reasons.
They're living somewhere as being around the proximity of those people who
enrich your life,
make it better when you write as a real leader.
You know what he's figured out how to do there is to create this atmosphere of,
first of all,
super supportive recruits guys,
right?
Recruited Tj Dillashaw who's the champion,
his weight class.
And then when they offered him a shot at Tj recently,
he's like,
yeah,
you know what?
I'll fight Frankie Edgar at one 45 let's,
let's just have a fucking super fight.
Let's get crazy.
Yeah.
You know,
you gotta love that,
right?
You got to love that.
He thinks like that,
but I just,
I just love that setup of all the houses on a block.
Yeah.
And you know,
that's going to be possible for some,
and I think that's great.
And one of the great things about what he's done to really make tribe,
you got to go back to rich and these different bonding experiences that allow
you to reach that level of trust.
You know,
shared,
shared suffering,
you know the people that you've been been in combat together,
like your eye and all those people.
That says a lot because it's certain point.
There's a lot of ways to test people,
you know,
to a certain degree and go through something together.
Obviously physical exertion like that,
like rolling with somebody,
you learn a ton about them or doing a psychedelic experience with somebody,
you know,
you both drink a coffee cup full Iowasca you're going to learn a lot about
somebody at that point.
Same with all of these different rituals that have done,
developed.
Put your hand in a,
in a Mitt full of bullet ants,
you're going to learn a lot about a motherfucker.
How He,
what happens when that pain hits and it's overwhelming,
you know,
and that,
those were key parts of these societies that we've lost.
And it just kinda happens to some people and you get this closeness,
you know?
And I think intentionally bringing that back is going to be really important as
well as these new tribal units form.
We have education and as far as mathematics,
we have education as far as history.
We have education as far as grammar and English language and literature and all
these different things that we teach the standard in school,
but we don't teach men especially we don't teach men martial arts.
And I think that martial arts just know,
having the ability to understand how to use your body to defend yourself
psychologically alleviates so much pressure that some people just face and go
through life with they,
they can't defend themselves.
And the psychological relieving of that I think is an aid to an enhancing and
understanding other aspects of your life.
Also along the way,
along the way you're doing martial arts,
you're doing something difficult and it's,
you push yourself very hard and you learn about like what are these?
What are these feelings inside you that make you want to quit when you know you
couldn't keep going.
If the instructor goes,
keep going,
keep going.
30 seconds left and you're like doing a flurry on the bag and you just want to
stop.
Like if you were alone,
you would stop,
but you keep going and then you understand that you can keep going and then you
understand,
okay,
well if I can keep going here,
I could keep going in a sparring session.
If I can keep going in a sparring session,
I can keep going in competition.
I can count on myself to when I feel really fucking uncomfortable to hold it
together because I've experienced that state.
I understand what it is and I refuse to let the limiting negative aspects of
that state affect my performance.
I will do everything that my body is physically capable of doing and nothing
less.
I'm not going to sell it short with a weak mind.
But until you've experienced that,
it's very difficult to have any confidence in your ability to overwhelm a any
sort of adversity or overcome any sort of diversity.
You don't really ever know if you can do it.
So you're always going to have this weird thing and the difference between men
that I know that have experienced that and do it,
you know,
do difficult things and even did not even fighting stuff like that either.
The same piece you get out of dudes who were like ultra marathon runners,
the guys who are triathletes pushing through that resistance,
they push through who they are,
they understand who they are better than most people and their religious,
a little bit more aware.
So a little bit more aware.
There's a,
and I think especially martial arts does that because of the emotional aspect of
the training.
It's so terrifying.
Sparrings terrifying all of it.
But in getting through that,
it makes everything else brighter.
It makes everything else lighter.
It's like it gives you,
it gives you more freedom with your mind.
Then if you're tussling with these ideas,
if you're tussling constantly with the fear of being like physically incapable
of defending yourself,
a massive deficits,
kind of a,
it's kind of a perfect storm of two things because it's put,
you're pushing through immense physical suffering at a certain point,
which is incredibly valuable.
Plus immense fear and a lot of other things have maybe one of the two like
marathon running,
immense physical suffering,
no fear,
Big Wave Surfing,
immense fear,
no physical sufferings that maybe when you get crashed into some coral or
something bad happens,
right?
But then those are good practices.
But I think at what you're hitting on is that martial arts hits both and so you
have to transcend both.
So you'll respond well in situations that are causing fear to come up and you'll
respond well in situations that are particularly challenging on the physical
aspect of things.
And it's almost like the opposite of that famous Musashi quote.
It said no the way broadly and you'll see it all things no the way narrowly and
you will be able to apply it broadly.
You know,
if you reach really great levels in something specific like that,
you'll be able to use that for the rest of your life and everything.
It's just,
I really think it should be almost required,
almost required and it doesn't mean you have to be good at it.
Just do it too,
just to get your state in a better place.
Can your mental state and a better place,
especially Jujitsu,
I think you know because he have no head trauma.
Really had trauma.
Yeah,
that's a big one.
Yeah and it's just,
I just think people need to do difficult things and I think life is too,
God damn amazing.
It's too soft for most people into it.
As far as like character building character is only like built necessarily under
pressure.
It's very hard to build character.
You know when just a person who's
won the lottery when you're three and you sat around all day and cake,
he just,
where's your character?
Like why?
Where's it coming from?
Like you kind of have to go through some shit and I think that's one of the
issues with a lot of people in this kind of new age movement and this the
hippies,
if you want to call them or whatever your name for him,
you know,
might be the people in that consciousness movement,
let's say,
is that there?
You know that there's some part of you when you meet some of them who haven't
really been tested where he's saying,
I see that you haven't really tested yourself under immense pressure,
you know,
and that you get this kind of feeling like what happens if things really get
shitty?
Am I going to be able to count on you and trust you?
All of these things that you're proposing there are.
They all gonna go to shit.
I have an instance.
I have an instinct that they might,
and so I think everybody on both sides or are missing this kind of the dualism
of having both,
of being able to reach high levels of consciousness,
but also put yourself on a mat with someone who,
you know,
inevitably in 30 to five 30 seconds to five minutes is gonna choke you out.
You know,
like know that you're going to go through that and what that put goes through
your body.
Being able to do both,
I think is the next wave.
You know,
two times too many times people are on the polarity of that,
you know,
they're one or the other.
They're either really good at,
at the Jujitsu side,
but they haven't,
you know,
push through the realms of consciousness either through Kundalini or
psychedelics or meditation or these other things.
And conversely,
on the other side,
they haven't tasted what it feel like to push through extreme fear and
adversity.
Adversity.
Yeah.
It's almost like your,
your car that you're driving through life will work better if you like running
over more mountains and it'll work better if you put it in danger.
It'll work better if you slam on the brakes more,
it'll work better.
Like that's,
this is what your vehicle is like.
You're in,
in,
in this compromising situation that we're in.
It's not compromise.
It's amazing.
We're in the best spot ever as far as like human history,
like we have great medicine,
we have great education.
Information is available to basically any human being can get a world class
education online.
But because of everything being so easy to get food and easy to get,
uh,
you know,
to take care of yourself in comparison to how it was when you're fighting off
predators,
you don't really use your body that much.
You don't really,
not a lot that's going on.
Not a lot of stress on the brain as far as like death,
life or death situations.
There's not a lot of fleeing at full speed running for your life,
trying to get up a tree as quick as you can.
There's not a lot of that,
you know,
and that tested sort of diminish its potential.
Yeah,
they did this thing on hunter gatherers and a,
the difference between the bone structure of the hunter gatherer and the bone
structure of the modern day man and they're,
they're looking at modern humans and like the deterioration of the mass of the
bones and the hands are getting smaller and that tended to getting weaker and
like,
like we're,
we're like,
we're becoming like those Goddamn gray aliens.
I mean,
we're like slowly but surely going from what we think of as a caveman,
like just fucking gnarly.
Those neanderthals especially,
they were like five foot five,
200 plus pounds,
just tanks,
giant bones and fucking thick heads and shit.
And I mean,
they were,
they were out there huffing it every day.
And because we're not doing that,
everything is like feminizing,
everything is like thinning.
Everything is like becoming weaker and weaker and weaker.
And then we're missing out on a key element of the magic of this fucking
experience.
You know,
this turn in this dimension,
part of the fun of it is feeling what the body can do and feeling those
feelings.
And if we turn into that gray alien type,
we're going to be fucking bummed out.
You know?
I mean,
I actually had a vision of that in my Iowasca session,
the last one that I went on where the,
this alien being came in and he was,
and I was like,
well,
what's it like being an alien?
Do you have anything to tell me?
And because he was just chilling there and he says,
well,
being human is very enviable because for us,
you know,
we have no physicality in our realm anymore.
That's been gone.
And you get to experience everything.
And he showed me these visions of exactly that,
like wrestling and fucking and eating crazy to not order.
No,
but even everything that we get to do all of the physical pleasures of this
world,
he's like,
yeah,
there's,
you know,
there's other pleasures of this other realm,
this realm of pure consciousness where everything is smooth,
where a generally in a state of bliss,
but we're missing the extremes of these physical pleasures.
So human life is enviable and it just discard that.
Say,
Nah,
I'm not interested.
We're fucking missing out,
man.
You missed out on vitality.
You know,
that's something that,
especially people that don't exercise,
they don't,
they don't take that into consideration when they dismiss it as being some ego
propping device.
Oh,
what are you doing?
Curls.
They're getting built up your quads,
man,
you're fucking smart.
You know,
they like somehow or another try to diminish the,
um,
the intelligence of what you're doing by pointing out the,
the benefits of it.
But I like pointing out that your muscles are larger and stronger somehow.
You must be stupid.
Like,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
it's a,
it's an adorable thing that they do.
It's like,
it's because it's so transparent.
It's so obvious.
Like you're being so silly that you're going through life with that shit body.
That's what's really going on.
Like if you just exercise like pretty much everybody that exercises get
stronger.
It really works.
Yeah.
They've been doing it for years.
I just keep doing it,
man.
You just keep doing it.
You get stronger when you get stronger,
your body works better.
When your body works better,
you do stuff easier.
Well,
it's so clearly the ego,
just restructuring of value systems so that they can be on top.
What's important?
Well not this,
that's actually a diminishment,
so therefore I'm on top and pretending that somehow or another
that if you are fit or if you are,
if you're muscular,
strong,
it's somehow or another,
you must be diminished mentally because that energy that you put into getting
those muscles,
you didn't,
you weren't studying and you want to go,
I'm a,
why are you studying all day?
You fuck you stunning.
23 hours a day.
You're not.
Then you have an hour to go to the gym just to go to the gym.
It's not that hard.
Like you're talking about something that's not nearly as difficult as you try to
predict your,
you're pretending it's like a lifestyle 24 seven choice that you have to make
and you got to keep away from knowledge.
And you know,
Doug,
you could get just as smart,
you know John Danaher,
who's like one of the most brilliant people you're ever gonna meet Jujitsu
instructor from New York.
He was a,
it was a philosophy major,
you know,
and he was a bodybuilder at the same time.
I mean he was just big when he was like in the power lifting and shit when he
first found Jujitsu and he took two Jitsu because he wanted to have some skills
and Casey was in altercations as a bouncer cause he was making a living doing
that at night while he was a student.
You know?
So it's like this idea that somehow or another strength or masculinity,
it's like,
it goes hand in hand with being an idiot.
Like it's,
it's hilarious that they've actually managed to somehow or another and not,
they like it some concerted effort,
but the week souls amongst us that don't want to really look at themselves
honestly and well,
and then the meatheads have the same prejudice on the other side.
They think,
oh,
you're doing yoga.
We're
exactly,
so they have the same prejudice when really eventually,
you know,
the wisest stuff.
We're just going to drop all that and say,
Hey,
I want to fucking do it all because that's what's capable for the human being.
That's what we're here to do.
Experience everything we can.
Yeah.
That's what we really should all be doing.
What's like this idea that you have to be in one camp or another camp?
Like were we closer to each other than we like to think.
And the moment we start looking at each other as like us or them,
you know,
like I had conversations with,
with people and they find out that,
you know,
you voted Democrat,
like,
oh Christ,
you're fucking one of them.
You mean you're telling me?
And they're like,
well,
ramp up their voice.
Like,
whoa dude,
relax,
relax.
You know like we're,
we're not necessarily in an argument here,
you know,
I guarantee you there's a lot of shit that I agree with that you agree with too.
Like we're,
we're probably a lot closer than you think.
A lot of things.
Well you know what was the biggest fucking Muslim in this country so Obama never
getting those conversations like chorus dude,
I can't even talk to you about that.
I don't even know where to begin.
I don't know.
I don't know where this is going.
But like they think that you are the enemy.
Like you get roped into the enemy and some you get categorized.
But if there was no democrat and there was no republican,
there was no teams,
there was just a bunch of stances and positions on issues that we would be,
we would all be way closer then when Dan you think it's just when you vote,
when you have representatives and one is blue and one is red and you're playing
some weird fucking like board game.
Like what is this?
There's a blue team and a red team.
Don't fucking stupid.
That is,
there's a blue states and red states like the divisiveness of that,
the almost,
almost something designed
to keep people at odds with each other because if you looked at it in terms of
just,
just the issues,
then you could debate the issues individually on their own merit and they
wouldn't be attached.
Like pro life is constantly attached to the right,
you know,
um,
there's certain gay rights constantly attached to the left,
you know,
a health care reform left,
finances,
anything,
anything that benefits business,
right?
It's hilarious.
It's so adorable that they've managed to pack package,
all this stuff there,
there a hacking into the dark side of tribalism and the dark side of tribalism
is when you have a group and fuck everybody else cause they're trying to take
what I have.
And all of these,
setting up of these camps is like a mental hack into this instinctual quality
that we developed.
And you see it and even sports fans,
you know,
these hooligans,
when their English soccer team in red wins or the blue one winds,
that's their whole life.
They're punching people,
they're stabbing people,
you,
they're trampling people.
Whatever.
This crazy identification with someone who's putting a ball in a net,
but it's the tribalism aspect that people are playing on and I think politicians
and everybody have kind of played to that.
When we realize when you level all of that,
yeah,
you can have your tribe and that's good,
but beware of the dark side,
which is these are my people.
Fuck everybody else.
Even the preppers kind of doomsday preppers have this kind of idea like I got
this thing and fuck everybody else.
Those people are crazy.
That shit is not going to work.
You're going to take your shit and everyone's going to find out.
They saw you on TV dummy.
They know where you have your pickles varied.
Like what are you looking at?
What kind of an asshole or you that prepare us for the worst,
but shows everybody your house and this is where we have our ammo.
Oh well now I know where to get the ammo.
When the fucking Zombie apocalypse hits,
I just get into the garage and I got the ammo and then you decide which family
with two kids comes knocking on your door.
You put give the food to.
It's just this kind of weird,
it's crazy.
It's this kind of weird thing.
Whereas I think seeing everybody is,
that could be me in a different circumstance and a different way.
That's me.
Oh,
that's me.
That's me.
That's a really cool practice to do actually that I've done as well.
Go out to a beach somewhere and imagine yourself as each individual.
Oh,
that's me.
I can see maybe where my thoughts have created this body type and this thing.
And obviously you're just playing a game,
but you're putting yourself actually in everybody's position and understanding
they're not that fucking different.
You know,
they just had different genetics,
different backgrounds and different choices that they made.
Yeah,
I've,
I've talked about it on stage that I had this experience where I wrote about it.
Um,
I had this experience when my,
uh,
my first daughter was about to be born and I was in Hawaii and I was on a boat
and I was super high and uh,
these dolphins were jumping around next to the boat and I was just,
I was on this insane edible.
I was so far gone that I had this like weird connection with these and
I realized like how intelligent they are and I thought like a wonder if they're
like people,
I wonder if like I lived at dolphins life,
I would be like a dolphin.
Like if you lived in that water,
like if you have,
you think of you who you are and if you were in a dolphin's body,
I wonder if you literally would be a dolphin.
Then I thought about it and I was like,
what if that's how every human being is that we're all exactly the same thing,
but we are living through different biological filters,
different life experiences,
different genetics.
But if you live my life,
you would be me.
And if I lived your life I would be you.
And then it's an illusion.
And that's what the illusion of separateness is really all about the deal.
Everyone's like,
there's not an illusion dude.
This guy beat the shit out of me.
I don't know him.
He's not me.
I'm not in him.
That guy's a dick.
You know what I mean?
Like people have that,
oh,
that girl fucking cut my hair.
That is not me cutting my hair turns me.
We are not one I'm going to fucking stab at home.
You know?
But if you lived her life,
that's where the illusion is.
The illusion is that because we live these separate experiences that if we all
had the agreement that we treat each other as if it was us living another life,
the world would instantly be better instantly if we could pass that.
I mean,
everybody wants to pass.
There's all sorts of radical ideologies that people push.
There's all sorts of radical religions and behavior choices and all sorts of
different things that people want other people to just subscribe to.
And one of the people do it here too.
But if it is a really simple one,
a really simple one that's almost a one liner,
treat everybody as if it's you living another life.
If you did do that,
if you,
if,
if it turned out to be true,
if we some fucking Nobel prize winning an egg had figured out in a laboratory
that if like you could literally take the essence of who is Aubrey,
Marcus and throat and Jamie Vernon's body,
you'd be Jamie if you lived his life up until now,
if they proved it mathematically.
And I think,
and I think that's possible and what you're hitting on is,
you know,
I call it,
so there's the golden rule,
do unto others as you would do unto yourself.
But I think there's the platinum rule and you know,
which supersedes that which very well might be do unto others because they are
yourself.
You know,
motherfucker just rewrote the golden rule g here that that mother fucker just
rewrote the golden rule.
It's the platinum role.
He'll fucking platinum rules better than the golden rule.
Yeah.
Damn Dude,
that's strong.
That's a very strong statement and you've totally dead on.
Yeah.
Treat them as if it's you.
That's a difference.
Not treat them because it is you.
Yeah.
Because it is you in a different life and a different filter and different
biological switches that have been hit.
I think that's why it's so hard to be around people that are falling apart.
Um,
I was at the comedy store the other night and this woman who used to be a
comedian,
I don't think she's the comedian anymore,
came around and she was drunk and fucked up and confused and she hadn't done
standup in a long time.
And she's probably like close to 60 now.
She's old as fuck,
but it just never worked out.
She's never,
she was like,
Oh,
me an open miker or 20 years ago.
But she would always kind of hang around still and,
uh,
to see her now,
you know,
it's,
it's really hard to see someone like,
like she did.
She would try to talk to us,
but no one could tell him anything.
And everyone's terrified.
She's going to say,
Hey,
can you guys put me up some night,
put me up on your show.
You know,
everyone's terrified.
She's gonna ask for some sort of comedy help,
you know.
But you've got to think like what does it feel like to be that person?
Like what,
what,
what's synapses don't fire?
What life experience stunts your emotional growth.
What puts you in a state of denial?
What gives you these blinders that you can't realize the fact that the audience
sees you in a way that you don't see yourself.
So this is,
this comedy thing is never going to work.
Like she just fucking,
you don't even know what you look like.
You don't know what you sound like.
You don't know how you behave and,
and then you see it manifesting itself 20 plus years later in this disastrous
rack of,
of kind of crazy lady.
And you're like,
wow man,
that could have been me.
You know,
if I was born in her body and lived her life and you,
you take into consideration how,
how difficult it is to turn from that state and improve.
Like we almost give someone no chance.
Like you never meet someone who's a total fucking loser at 40 and then you meet
him at 45 and he's like the best guy ever.
Like nobody does it.
Minimum is a motherfucker.
It's really hard to change.
But when you have that attitude where you start looking at people just as you
said,
that could be me.
The only proper response is empathy.
You know,
even if it's someone that perpetrates something against you and this is,
you know,
a really challenging thing to do.
Yeah.
You know,
you want to prevent that.
If someone goes to fuck you up,
then fuck them up,
that's fine.
That's your right to defend yourself and protect but not do it out of anger.
Do it out of necessity,
out of necessity.
And then the only feeling that you should have towards that is a feeling of
pity.
It's too bad that that person got to a place where they had to do that,
where that was,
what their decision mechanism was.
And it doesn't mean that you just accept it,
but it means that that's really the only thing.
But instead we like to,
you know,
keep up this illusion of separateness.
Like fuck that guy and shit.
Yeah,
exactly.
But really only pity,
only pity and empathy really come from that.
And that's the,
that's a real state of bliss.
You know,
like the Tibetan monks,
that's what they're meditating on all the time.
It's getting to that state of empathy.
Well,
to get to that state of empathy,
just look at everybody like their yourself and that's the key way to get in
there.
Yeah,
try,
try pushing that in the public school system.
I just,
that was one of the key tenants of the public school system.
That would work,
man.
Yeah,
it really would work.
It's almost like a little,
a simple key unlocks a totally different start doing and start doing little,
you know,
little things where it's like,
what would you know,
put yourself in that other person's body like,
right from their perspective.
Or I don't know what school drills you could do.
Like write a story as this person,
your friend,
you know,
and,
and then tell him what,
you know,
feel what it's like to go through that.
Like live these other multiple lives and you'll have,
you'll understand that.
Yeah.
You know,
that could be me and what and,
and it'll start to evaporate that from an early age.
I think putting in the school system is brilliant.
I think that's what needs to happen.
Yeah.
There's a lot of things that need to happen with the school system,
but that would definitely help the way that was taught as a tenant and school
instead of reading the fucking pledge of allegiance.
Right.
You know,
I mean to the republic for which it stands.
Stop.
What does that mean?
Do you guys know what that means?
One Nation under God,
you know that that didn't even exist kids until the fucking red scare of the
1950s he used to say one nation indivisible,
with liberty and justice for all.
But when we had a fight off the Goddamn commies,
we put it God under God.
You fucks.
I mean,
most people think that that was like how this nation was founded.
One Nation under God.
No,
that,
that was in the fifties but everybody was losing their fucking mind and people
were going on trial on a regular basis for being communists.
They were blackballing people that look,
think of the crazy shit that you and I have done and think of if we were living
in the 1950s and they,
I did.
Did you in fact go to the jungle of Peru,
Mr Marcus?
And did you in fact in by been several toxic medicines you would,
you'd look like a fucking complete nut if they brought you into some sort of a
court setting in the 1950s but back then you could even go to a communist
meeting.
You couldn't go.
Like,
what is this about?
Like what are you guys pushing you pushing comp socialism and what does that
mean?
Like no one,
you know,
you do whatever you want.
Like do you get paid by the government?
Like do you,
how do you contribute?
Where's the money coming from?
Like maybe just go and try to figure out what the fuck everyone's talking about.
And especially amongst creative folk.
I'm sure there's always been a lot of alternative thinkers,
whether Erin or on the right track.
Sure.
There's been a lot of weird people that think outside the box always.
So in the 1950s these guys are probably looking at communism and go,
okay,
and let's see,
look,
I got my fucking,
my fortune read by dianetics wants,
whatever.
I did one of those tress meters.
I said,
okay,
let me see what you got.
What have I got on the list?
Because of that man,
you know,
like this was,
this was what was going on when they put under God in our pledge of allegiance.
It was that kind of madness,
insane thinking they had to put,
you know,
yeah,
well these witch hunts have existed.
And again,
tapping into these old mechanism,
these,
these fear responses,
these tribalism instincts,
and you know,
these witch hunts,
we think all the witch hunts are over.
Well,
at one point they're called witch hunts because they were literally hunting,
which is throwing them in the water and seeing if they would swim,
you know?
And if they drowned,
then they weren't a which if they swim,
they were,
which,
and even worst should happen to him.
Very good.
You're completely fucked.
Either way.
They weren't a wish.
So sorry about your kid,
Mr. Johnson.
I thought she was a witch.
It turns out she was just a shitty swimmer.
Yeah.
So that was the witch hunt.
But that's going on today and it's going on.
You know,
the area that we see at the most is in the psychedelic medicines.
people
are being hunted for manipulating their own consciousness.
You know,
even with scientific research coming back that it's beneficial.
They're being hunted down in these kind of crazy ways and thrown in cages for
manipulating their own consciousness.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
There's not too many people getting arrested and thrown in jail for doing it.
They're getting arrested and thrown in jail for selling it.
But either way,
you know,
it's,
it's all stupid.
You should be able to sell things that are good.
It's really that simple.
This idea of these people that are non-experienced in these,
these states of mind they'd done,
they don't know really know what they're talking about.
From a personal level.
Dictating the legality of those experiences is ridiculous.
And if those are the people that are locking you up,
I'm kind of on your side like you should be able to sell mushrooms.
Did you grow it?
Yeah,
you should.
You deserve some money.
Did you grow tomatoes?
Yeah,
I'll pay you for those two.
I don't want to grow.
I don't want to empower girls to get it.
People don't sell it.
What the fuck are we talking?
He's a farmer.
He's a fucking farmer of awesome shit.
And that's what a mushroom dealer is.
He's a farmer of awesome shit.
He's on a drug dealer.
You've done and you're,
you're subject to the whims of these people and that's the,
the people that are willing to lock you in a cage in the first place.
They're fools.
Like this is like the worst way to deal with someone who's doing something to
alter their consciousness.
To put them in a fucking cage,
I guess is the worst.
You're going to think he was paranoid before.
You know?
Imagine if you go to jail for weed,
how fucking paranoid you get when you get high.
Yeah,
I mean it's preposterous.
And imagine if we were the owner of a,
of a pretty smart pet.
You know,
let's say we had a pet chimpanzee,
you know,
it's a very smart pet and the chimpanzee found something that reliably made him
laugh his ass off and made him a better chimpanzee.
You know,
what kind of owner would we be if we took that chimp and then threw him in the
worst conditions in the tiniest cage and took away his freedom for doing that?
We'd think that person is a fucking desperate call animal control.
He's a fucking crazy person.
It's called law enforcement.
Aubrey,
you're obviously not aware of what goes on there on the highways and byways of
America's great.
I pledge of allegiance to the flag.
Instead I pledged to treat everybody as if it's me living another life.
Yeah.
If we started off every class like that,
every,
every school I pledge to treat,
everybody I meet is if it's me living another life,
everybody adheres to that.
Everybody across the board got,
damn,
it would be a better place.
Wouldn't be so much ferocious competition now that would suck.
Some Fun Shit happens when you don't like your opponent.
You know?
That's true.
But I don't know that,
that that has to go,
you know?
I mean,
I think that you can look at that opponent like,
all right,
he's the motherfucking mountain that's going to bring the best out of me.
You know?
And then so you're going to want to find that.
Like I love it when Daniel Cormier,
I said,
I mean obviously the fight wasn't that great,
but he said,
you know,
I've been waiting my whole life for a man who's my equal Jon Jones.
Be that man.
You know,
that idea I think is embodies the beauty of what MMA can be.
It's like finding somebody that will push you to the point that you never been
pushed before.
And I think that'll still exist even in this state.
You'll just look at them like,
that could be me.
This is me.
No worries.
We'll see what we can do to bring the best out of each other.
Yeah,
but not a few.
If you hate them,
it's better.
Federal Wise,
rich two people hate each other.
It's better to watch Richard some shit.
Talking going on.
Like we were talking about the chocolate Dell,
Tito Ortiz fight.
Like when Chuck Liddell and Tito,
they didn't like each other.
This just a lot of bad blood.
So when chuck beat up Tito,
that Ra was like extra juicy.
Oh you know,
it was extra crazy to watch because there was so much like when Ronda Rousey
fought Misha Tate and they went through that whole season,
the ultimate fighter together and fuck you and as long as fucking craziness and
all this anger and then Rhonda beats her ass and gets her in an arm bar again
after all that,
like you're like,
wow,
that was wild to watch.
You know,
it's,
you're watching something like super primal.
Like you're not just watching it on a tactical level where you watch two very
high level martial arts.
Like she was the first person to push her,
you know,
deep into the second and third round.
I think she caught her in the fourth round,
if I remember correctly.
It was third or fourth.
Um,
but point being like they just didn't like each other and that made you choose
here.
They're amazing.
Raises the emotional stakes.
And I think that's also what's interesting too.
Like how were they going to perform when the stakes are even this high and even
this site and even this high and when they hate each other,
you know that it just escalates things to an even higher degree.
And that's I think why we even like watching the playoffs is it's not that
somebody gets a little trophy and that's part of it,
but it's,
oh now the stakes are higher.
Now people are going to be crying after the game if they lose and they're going
to be ecstatic if they win.
And like the regular season when it's like,
yeah,
okay,
it's just a game.
When the stakes get higher,
it becomes more interesting because we're interested in the reaction that humans
are going to have in these different scenarios.
Yeah,
we don't,
we wonder how we would fare and you know,
I remember,
uh,
being a kid and uh,
watching boxing matches and seeing like guys like get beat up against the ropes
or something like that.
And you know,
you almost like see yourself moving.
You're like trying to figure out,
well,
should he do,
he's got to get out of there.
He's going to hit that guy like,
but you don't really know how to fight,
but you're still watching it and you're just like,
ah,
ah.
It's like you're putting yourself sort of in there in some way.
You know,
you're watching it,
you want your,
you know,
especially back then I always had a guy,
it was,
I was rooting for this guy.
It was written for that guy.
You know,
you always like boxing fans would always have like,
you'd have like a guy you'd pick like I'm a Dale,
a horror fan,
fucking bro who this is a Chavez.
The Shit,
like people would have those,
those fucking guys that they would stick with.
And when your guys getting beat up or he's in trouble,
you know,
appreciating it on a technical level,
you're almost like,
oh,
you're almost like getting beat up yourself.
I remember one of the most terrifying moments I had because I,
I've done striking since I was little,
never that serious,
but I had a lot of instructors who were very complimentary early,
you know,
so they had me believing that man,
Aubrey,
you hit someone,
they're done son.
You know,
like I had this kind of false belief.
And obviously once I started sparring,
I realized that that wasn't the case.
But I had some,
had some remnants of that that I was carrying.
And then I saw Kimbo slice in one of these street fights,
right?
Oh yeah.
And in bare knuckle fight and this other huge dude catches him with a left hook
and Kimbo just drops his hands,
go get me good,
fuck off,
fit me again.
And just leans forward with his head and the other dude hits him again and does
nothing.
It does nothing now.
You're dead motherfucker and it catches him with this upper cut and just blows
up his face,
exploded his face.
And I was like,
there's nothing I could do to that guy.
If he was that fired up and charging.
And it was this terrifying moment where you realize what your boundaries are in
the world,
you know?
Like I couldn't hit him and knock him out,
you know,
everything I had been told was bullshit.
No way I could do anything to that man at that point.
Well,
physical size and structure,
so giant and he actually knows how to fight too,
but physical size and structure,
so fucking big.
It's so,
it's so,
so important when it's,
you know,
we look at,
in terms of its success in weight classes and the really big strong guys don't
necessarily tend to be the best guys in the weight class.
It's about like whose body is optimized for that weight class?
So you don't really want to be carrying around a lot of muscle,
but if you are and someone's smaller than you,
it makes you better.
It makes you fucking bigger and stronger and everything works better.
It might not work as good.
I guess another guy who's 240 pounds who's like got a leaner body and better
lungs,
but you know,
Kimbo slice is a god damn giant human being who can punch people in the face all
the time with no gloves on.
Yeah.
Like Jesus,
he's fighting again.
You know,
it's funny,
Ken Shamrock,
he was the guy that,
you know,
I think never really fought to what his physical capability was like.
His hardware had a certain potential,
like the limits on it.
Like if you look at him like a computer,
it's like,
oh,
it's got this much,
you know,
these attributes,
this much remedy,
this much memory,
this much ram I blah.
But the software,
running it inside the cage,
I felt like never optimize what his gifts were.
You know,
it's another one of those interesting things where it's psychologically,
it didn't bring the best out of what his frame could be.
Yeah.
That's interesting man.
You know,
he had problems before you ever even got on the ultimate fighter was his knees.
His knees are pretty significantly diminished.
He has like serious like bone on bone,
like arthritis type conditions in his knees.
And so like for him like grappling,
is it an issue kickings and issue.
All those things are issues,
you know and he,
you know,
he had a lifetime of sports football and you know,
did a lot of a striking training.
Obviously all the over the years,
man,
shoot that shit up.
Especially football.
Football is brutal on the knees.
Man carrying porn stars in and out of Limos.
That happens.
He's got to do that a lot.
Do that.
They're probably like fuck him.
He's also,
he's in a weird time.
Like he might be like a little too late for like all the rejuvenation shit that
they're coming up with right
now.
Like they're three d mapping meniscus.
Have you seen this dude?
They have something like,
it was some article about how the Three d mapping essentially what it looks
like.
It's like a scaffolding for meniscus and there's certain proteins in this.
They inserted into the space between your joint,
you know,
where your meniscus says,
which you know now when you get it scope.
Like I,
my,
I had my left knee scoped a few years back.
Like you don't get any extra padding back.
It's it like you're patting has diminished now.
Like it knee doesn't bother me.
It feels way better than when it was when it was fucked up.
But now what they're doing is they're just taking it all out and they're putting
this,
this three d thing that they three d print and with these proteins and it,
your body starts building meniscus inside this framework.
Somehow or another,
I've just,
I might be totally butchering this,
but essentially they have artificial meniscus for the first time ever.
They,
they,
they really weren't able to fix that thing is actually two different solutions I
think currently on the horizon.
But this need meniscus generated with three d implants.
Look at this so you can watch it.
It's just a perfect fit.
I mean,
we're going to get to the point where our bodies are just like cars,
you know,
you can upgrade any system,
you can change it out.
And I think the crazy thing that we alluded to,
they'll come a point where I believe we'll be able to upload our consciousness
into a brand new car.
You know,
and that will be the point of,
of immortality to a certain degree because you could just keep creating these
new cars and then just upload your car.
Oh Shit,
I fucking fuck this one up.
I got cancer,
I crashed it.
No worries me all over into this other one would.
If that's hell,
what does,
that's how would,
if the wood of heaven is just getting over this body and achieving the next
state of consciousness,
which is nonlocal completely and dependent upon your physical prison,
but you were like,
dude,
you were just going to get out of jail and you decided to transfer your sentence
to some cyber prison.
Well,
you'll live in your own mind forever and ever and ever repeating yourself ad
nauseum through space.
Instead,
you could have been one with the great consciousness of the universe.
Obviously,
if no one who passed over to the other side could communicate,
you know,
they'd be just yelling from the other doubt.
Do Die.
You'll see.
It's amazing.
You get to start again.
You get to start again anyways,
and it's more awesome because you get this side and then that side,
who fucking knows?
Man,
I'm not totally enthusiastic about the prospect of becoming one of those gray
aliens though.
No,
I've been in either,
I've been talking about that for years
about that simulation theory.
That's the thing that I talked to this Guy Richard Trill who was from the JPL
laboratories.
Um,
when I was doing that,
Joe Rogan questions,
everything show and when you
tops for whatever reason,
when he talked like a serious legitimate working scientist and an actual,
you know,
doctor of science,
a talk to them about it,
it just makes it seem like way more palatable than if you talked to Duncan and
Duncan talks about it.
It seems a little bit more sexy.
But this guy,
what he was saying
essentially is that it's basically inevitable that we're going to come up with
some sort of an artificial reality that is indiscernible from the reality that
we're currently enjoying.
It's going to be artificial.
We're going to create it.
We're going to be totally manipulate it.
It's going to evolve over time.
It's going to get better and better as the technology moves on and on.
It's going to get to a point where it's you,
you,
you literally not gonna be able to tell the difference.
And if that's the case,
has that already happened?
And if it has already happened,
would you be able to be aware of it?
What would you be if we had gotten past this?
Well,
if you go back to fucking gorillas,
you look at gorillas,
you look at lower primates.
So look at these dick swinging monkeys hanging out in Africa.
You know,
just swinging from tree to tree until somebody figured out how to become a
person right over all these years,
however the hell it went.
Um,
look at what they look like.
Look at a gorilla and then look at a person and look at the feminized person of
the modern era and then look at those.
God Damn Aliens.
It's almost like that's the archetype.
Like we know that's coming.
Like we know the big head,
no mouth.
You don't need to talk your,
you were permanent sunglasses because you fucked up the ozone layer.
You know your skin is like some sort of a gray bulletproof material that we've,
you know,
you don't have any sex organs cause you,
you,
you can experience any pleasurable Kundalini Yoga state in your mind anytime you
want,
like regular blow jobs.
It's just not that exciting when you can,
you know,
travel from dimension to dimension.
That might even be how they were arriving and going back and forth.
But it might be a part of them.
Mrs. Head,
Mrs Muscle cars,
Mr [inaudible],
obviously the vision state,
you don't know if it's real or in your mind,
whatever.
I don't even make that discernment.
But when I was in that vision state and talking to him,
they missed it.
They missed it,
We're lucky like where the right spot.
We got the honey hole.
This is the goldilocks zone.
We get to access everything,
we get to access everything and we get,
it was a time where we're sort of working it out like as a culture people are
working it out.
I think there's a lot of like the w in the working out,
there's like a lot of noise and chaos and shit that's going on.
I think tea party people and fucking occupy people and the,
you know there's a lot of,
there's a cult of personality and cultive ideology that's going along with a lot
of these things,
but throughout all of it,
throughout people complaining about fat shaming and you know this the,
although the Weird Uber sensitivity that you see today,
the trend though,
all of it seems to be this like kind of like emerging understanding of how we
interact with each other.
It's like it says this is battles back and forth.
There's waves,
but like if you're looking at like what is this?
When this all this water settles,
what am I seeing here?
What am I seeing here?
I'm seeing a merging,
understanding,
emerging understanding and along the way there's a lot of competing factions
that want to be the most morally upstanding and take the high ground and be the
one who was always there to call bullshit.
And the social justice warriors that are just looking to be mean so that they
can prove to you the way to live,
right?
Like looking to find people aren't living the way they're leaving and just
shitting all over them.
A shame them into it.
A different way of thinking.
All this is just a,
is this a merging?
It's an emerging understanding of,
of what we are and the connectivity that we share and the demands.
Like when you see like these black lives matter marches and um,
these protests,
people wouldn't walk around these,
I can't breathe shirts.
They're,
they're,
they're expanding.
This understanding of the reach of the upset people.
Like this is not a minor thing that you can only,
you know,
vote about every four years.
This is something you can put a giant ripple and the entire culture right now by
everybody just wearing a bunch of tee shirts that say something on it.
And then everybody realizes like,
okay,
this is,
it's not just a social media trend.
It's not just a Hashtag on Twitter and Facebook.
It's also like the,
the,
the entire country,
like a big chunk of it collectively saying,
hey,
this is fucked up.
Like we can,
we can do better.
And Oh,
we can talk about this.
you know,
we're connected in some fucking weird way now.
Well we can kind of organize shit like this collectively.
And you know,
there's no real leader,
there's no real leader of any of those moments,
you know?
But,
but people gravitate towards them.
Yeah.
And so those things,
they all have that in common.
They all have this like this new connectivity thing in common.
And I think that's,
that's really the trend
and were able to draw wisdom pieces of wisdom from all different disciplines,
you know?
And that's been something cool that I've seen as I've gotten,
you know,
the ability to reach more different people,
experts in certain things,
you know,
we'll come in and add a little piece of understanding from their traditional
scope where,
you know,
most people wouldn't even get that.
Put that in part of their framework and then you get to add that piece and add
this piece over here.
Like,
you know,
I can get a piece from Dunkin about Buddhism,
and,
and one of these great pieces that he added recently is the Buddhist have a name
for that,
that visceral feeling you get right before you do something bad and get angry at
someone or,
or you know that emotional well the Buddhist have a name for that little feeling
that comes up,
you know,
I was like,
Oh yeah,
I've felt that little fucking thing that comes out.
It's like this rush of energy right before you do something,
you know,
you really know that you shouldn't do.
And then so you add that little piece of understanding that the name of that
thing is this.
So I can be more conscious of it and aware of it.
And then I have another friend,
Ted,
who studies the Christian texts and puts new meaning to what those things were
before they were manipulated for power and kind of maneuvered and like,
ah,
okay.
So he can add that.
And then so you start to piece together this understanding where of course
there's no leader.
It's just led by,
you know,
truth and consciousness.
And that's,
I think the next,
the next wave is just finding what's,
what's feels real,
what feels right,
what you can use to make your life better.
Also,
we just know there's so much information available today.
I think it's easier to kind of get an understanding of what's tripping you up.
You know,
it's easier to get an understanding of like there's a lot of people that behave
in a certain way.
Like that redneck song we were talking about and they've been supporting
that and they were the main man.
He had to do what he had to do.
You know,
he had to do what he had it.
Do you know what?
I'm playing this,
you leave a man alone,
we got to do what you going to do.
And that sort of like
perpetuating that over and over and over again.
Like if you do that over a long period of time,
the kid can ruin an entire area.
Like if a bunch of people think like that,
like,
oh,
this area is polluted with this idea,
right?
Like it's gets polluted,
polluted with he got do what he gotta do.
You know like there's areas of the country that for the longest time were
preluded where if you were in an interracial relationship,
you couldn't walk down the street.
If you walk down the street,
you would risk physical attack because you had a black girlfriend or you had a
white girlfriend and you're a black guy or whatever that was.
That was a reality for a long time.
In the south,
it's still a reality in some spots.
There's places you go is weird places in Texas we'd take a few left turns and
you drive for a few hours and all of a sudden you're in this fucking weird
place.
And there are some people that don't have a whole lot of contact with the
outside world.
That's an outlier.
That's like one of those weird bases that they would go to on star wars when
they needed fuel.
You know,
like,
Whoa,
fuck are we doing out here?
Like it's get out of here going,
oh you know,
that's literally where you are.
You're in your,
you were in a colony,
like some weird post that never caught on and it's in the middle of some weird
place east Texas and you're like,
wow,
the flunk,
I was nice.
Those spots are still real man.
They're still real and they're getting less real all the time.
And I think,
you know,
the big push is always just that human beings are constantly trying to improve.
I mean,
we constantly try to improve everything and we're going to try to improve
culture and relations and understanding.
And if you look at the way things are now as opposed to the way they were just
in the early 19 hundreds I mean the changes are pretty,
been pretty fucking dramatic from 1900 to 2015 is,
you know,
mentally,
but it's only 115 years,
115 years in the real world is like God damn,
that's a blink of an eye and he's a fucking blink of an eye.
If you track,
if you chart time versus change,
it's,
it takes this hockey stick curve way up because things are going so fast.
But I think one point that you've made often is,
you know,
these conditions that are really fucked up,
they have a reaction on the other side.
You know,
they form resistance that allows people to actually propel themselves even
farther in the other direction.
You know,
it's like the action has a reaction.
So the bias towards,
you know,
the racial bias for example,
can actually potentially propel people the other side to make greater leaps in
consciousness and understanding what we're talking about,
that we're all just ourselves living another life.
You know,
like these,
these conditions can create a positive response.
And I think that's kind of what we're seeing at this point.
Yeah.
And then the social justice warrior overreaction is really just an a reach.
It's like a comedian.
It makes it Shitty joke or you know,
uh,
it's,
I mean it's essentially the same kind of thing.
It's like it's just missing the mark,
you know,
I think there's a lot of white people specially when anything goes out wrong
where they like are struggling to appear down,
you know?
And they'll sometimes be racist against white people in order to show that they
love black people so much and they're not racist at all is a bunch of people
that I follow and I can't tell you who they are because then they'll know and
they'll change their behavior and it'll affect my studies.
But it's fascinating to see people like right.
Racist stuff against white people and think it's okay.
Like you're allowed to generalize against white people.
No fucking goofy.
That is like,
I know a lot of really fucking cool white people.
And I know that's not popular to say like for some reason you're supposed to be
embarrassed about being white.
And if you are,
you definitely embarrassed of knowing why people that you like and you have to
like talk about how many black people you know that you like.
I know a lot of black people,
I like to,
but I also know a lot of awesome fucking white people and I think generalizing
towards any fucking gender ethnicity,
but it's stupid.
I don't,
I'm not going to do it.
I'm not going to pretend.
Yeah,
changing,
modifying any aspect of your behavior one way or another because of
identification with the color of the genetics that is just perpetuating it.
You know,
even further that idea of separateness that my tribe,
your tribe.
So overcompensating is in itself a form of racism to a certain degree.
You know,
just be real.
Just treat people as fucking as humans.
Don't worry about overcompensating.
They're compensating.
And that's also in terms of sexism,
because there's a lot of men who are sexist against men.
Yeah,
they really are.
They're like,
they'll take a woman's side like automatically to be a white knight.
And that's one of the things that people hate on the Internet.
They white nights.
People get crazy when they catch someone doing it when it's pretty obvious what
they're doing.
When someone is not looking at the objective facts or the dude,
what it,
okay,
what was really going on here?
What's the real story?
And they had an automatically,
aside with the woman's with a woman's take on things,
and when you see that,
especially when it gets revealed,
the one was full of shit later,
it's always so juicy and glorious.
I love following those fucking trails and watching it all play out.
It's just,
it's so bizarre.
It's so bizarre to watch that behavior that Smiggle from the fucking Lord of the
rings like behavior.
And that's really what it's like.
If there's something that they're doing,
they're like,
it's like you're distorting reality for your own benefit to try to appear that
you're hot.
You're adhering to a higher moral standard than those around you to make
yourself look more desirable.
Right.
It's really that simple.
And it's fucking gross.
And People's,
you know,
at that point,
people's belief detectors,
that thing that we use to know when someone's coffee and cracked,
they start going haywire.
You know,
gears start flying.
I feel like you're fucking up to something here.
Yeah.
This is not just you.
And so the belief detectors go crazy.
Yeah.
It's the Beta thinking.
No,
it's okay to be Beta snow slot.
It's not
good for you.
You don't have to be alpha either.
I feel like there's a state of acceptance,
you know,
that you should probably achieve instead of either or,
just being what?
Being what you're capable of being.
Yeah.
That's it.
You don't have to try to be alpha.
There's this one quote that I've been kind of stuck on recently and it pertains
to,
you know,
just starting it right now at this point.
And it's from William Butler Yeats.
And he said,
do not wait to strike to the iron is hot,
but make the iron hot by striking and that God is not Erin's work cause an idiot
throw it doesn't work that way.
You got to throw the iron in there.
The fuck dude,
this fucking,
I know it's blacksmith.
Exactly.
But you know,
as a poet is a pause,
just being silly.
So silly.
Boy,
it's never hit anything.
Strike to make the iron high.
It doesn't work that well.
Things do get hot when you smash them going,
even have to fucking be really ineffective when you're striking
truth.
We've dismantled Butler Yates as a,
as a blacksmith,
but
no,
just fucking go at it by start.
Just start doing it.
You know what I mean?
We're talking all this philosophy about what you can and that may seem out of
reach to people like,
oh,
how am I going to do that?
How would I,
how would I do martial arts?
I've never even come close to that.
Well,
you just do it.
You don't wait for this perfect opportunity when job and money and everything
aligns and you read your fucking horoscope in the paper and it says you're going
to try new things this day and everything's just perfect.
Just do it.
Just go out there and do a little bit.
Do it.
Anthony Bordain started Jujitsu at 58
58 no athletic background.
Used to do heroin when smoked cigarettes five years ago.
I mean this guy started Jujitsu at 50 fucking eight years old.
Now he does it every day.
He doesn't like two hours a day as a private lesson every day and takes a class
every day.
Like what the fuck,
man?
It takes a class then he works on all the Shitty did wrong with an instructor
and the guy goes over positions with them.
Yeah.
Anybody.
You can do things.
Okay,
so as long as you,
you know,
you can figure out a way to finance it,
and if you're not well,
there's ever,
well,
what do I do that that's the problem.
You're on your own path.
Fuck face we,
I might be,
you live in another life,
but in your life you've got to get your own shit together.
I don't have time to figure out what you should do.
Okay.
That's what you're supposed to do.
And I don't know you dude.
That's the other problem.
You know,
you can't give anybody advice because you know,
like if you're talking to someone and they want to be a lounge singer and they
sounded like shit and you go,
well first of all,
lounge singing.
I don't know if there's a future in that.
And second of all,
dude,
your voices dog shit,
I don't know what to tell you.
Like that guy has got to figure out how to make his voice good.
That's a lot of work.
He's got to revive lounge singing.
He's got a fucking you,
you can't give everyone advice,
but what you can do
is
have these kinds of conversations.
Be really honest about what's worked and what hasn't worked for you,
and point out all the shit that you're noticing in this crazy world.
That's what we've been able to do.
That's what most folks that are online that are tuned into the world have been
able to do with information and news and,
and,
and just discussion that that's going on now.
And that really hasn't ever taken place like this before amongst people where
people were like debating issues all across the country and whether it's fucking
Obamacare or whether it's the fucking invasion of Persia,
whatever the fuck it is isn't even a country anymore.
You know what I'm saying?
Anything that's going on in the world,
the,
the ability to discount,
to write blogs,
to discuss it,
to have people like we leaving comments on those blocks,
to have people writing tweets,
responding to those tweets,
those tweets becoming articles.
Let's debate the merits of this tweet and these,
this is like,
whether it's right or wrong and there's ideologically driven,
whether it's honest or manipulated,
it's a weird exchange.
There's an exchange.
There's an exchange of data that's going on now in this really weird state that
I think we're just so caught up in it that were not realizing how much it's
changing.
Like,
well,
you're not supposed to say retard anymore.
You know that,
yeah.
There's slowly but surely closing out on all the words that might potentially
hurt people's feelings.
You're not supposed to say,
you know all the,
the,
the standard ones,
right?
Like Fag.
And that's supposed to say the,
any,
any racial slurs,
those are off the window.
Those are getting money removed from our culture,
like over a period way quicker than it's ever happened before.
They're going at it the wrong way.
They're saying these things can hurt you.
So they're telling people that they're vulnerable.
You're vulnerable,
so because these things can hurt you,
so we're going to remove these things.
Whereas really the message should be that you're fucking invincible.
That word can't hurt you unless you let,
that word hurts you.
You know,
you have the right of your own sovereignty of how you feel about yourself.
That someone saying a word shouldn't make you feel any different way.
Oh,
that's interesting.
You feel that way.
I'm sorry that you're in a state that you have that much anger and prejudice
that you feel that way,
but it doesn't affect me.
You,
Richard Gere,
that that's,
that's the,
that's the way that you know that that's the way that we got to do it.
Not remove all of these potential things that can hurt you.
Just tell people,
hey motherfucker,
you're invincible as far as your emotional state if you want to be.
Also,
it's really you.
You make a person more vulnerable when you make words taboo,
you make those words have more power.
Whether those words are racial,
you know that there are about gender or sexual orientation whenever the slurs
are,
you make them way more powerful when you make them taboo.
You know,
if you call someone a fucker like that,
if that hurts your feelings,
we can't talk like,
Hey fucker,
come on man.
Like if you know,
like if if someone does something,
knocks a drink over on your lap like,
hey fucker,
what up man?
You're like,
if you can't say that to someone,
you can't be friends with that person.
Right?
You can't.
They do too.
God Damn sensitive.
But if a guy spilled a drink in your lap and he was gay and you're like,
you faggot,
like Whoa,
everybody just dropped their drinks at the bar.
What did he say?
Did you hear the noise he made?
What is the noise or came of his mother wasn't having Jane Jane.
Oh whoa,
I can't wait.
It made that noise.
What is his intent?
What is really going on in his head?
Does he not know that that's a taboo word?
I can,
everybody just shuffled out of the party.
Well I guess his fucking party's over and people leave.
Like there's certain circles where if you did something like that just even as a
joke do,
you would automatically get ostracized.
You would automatically get like so is that smart to give a word that much
power?
No.
But are they on to something that you shouldn't be the type of person that wants
to use that word in a negative way?
Yes,
but are they not on to something cause they forgot about humor.
And one of the beautiful things about humor as you say shit,
you don't really mean because it's a funny thing to do.
It's,
it's,
what's funny about it is that,
you know,
someone doesn't really mean it like calling your gay friend of faggot cause he
spilled his drink on you.
It's funny,
we would all laugh if we were hanging around with Justin Martin down.
He spilled a drink on my lap.
I wouldn't do,
I wouldn't say that.
I would never call him a faggot.
But if Jamie did cause Jamie's I kind of guys from Columbus,
Ohio,
that's how they are out there.
They just think of Faggot tourettes
but you know,
if,
if anybody has a problem with that,
like you'd either either think that Jamie's really capable of being homophobic
in using a slur to like he hate you so much.
It has simple act of,
of,
of lack of coordination and,
and an accident they'll spelt beverage leads to his fucking unleashing of these
horrible phrases at you.
Come on.
Well,
it's like,
you know,
you're a parent and when you have a kid and didn't they do something like they
fall down and they kind of bumped their knee or something.
If,
if you go,
oh my God,
what did you do?
Are you okay?
They're going to think they're injuries way fucking worse.
They're going to freak out.
Like,
oh my God,
you're freaked out.
I'm,
I belief detector is saying that you believe something terrible is happening.
So something terrible is happening where it'd be like,
you're right,
get up.
It's all good.
You know,
dusted off.
They'll be like,
oh,
okay.
Then maybe they'll cry a little bit,
but they'll feel okay about it.
And in what we're doing in societies were saying,
oh my God,
he said Faggot.
Oh my God.
It's telling that person that we believe that this is really hurting you.
So it's actually causing the antithesis of what the goal is.
Where does she'd be saying,
say whatever the fuck you want.
It doesn't fucking matter.
You know,
you shouldn't be the kind of person that's saying it maliciously.
Yes.
You know?
And that's,
and that's the other part of what we've been talking about.
But if no matter what is said,
it doesn't matter.
You're a human being and your psyche has made a diamonds in the world is full of
fucking pillows.
Like that's it.
Whoa strong word.
Um,
I sh I see their point.
I see wanting to never be around someone who drops and bombs,
you know,
and,
and wanting to not be around someone who's prejudice against someone because
it's the consciousness that's the problem.
It's not the words we're looking to downstream.
We're trying to look at these downstream effects.
But really the problem there is you're with an unconscious person who fails to
see the platinum rule,
which is we're all the same fucking person.
Yeah.
And the,
the real,
the real attention should be focused on enhancing our,
our understanding of each other are enhancing our understanding of our,
our true connectivity and not of demonizing the noises that you make face.
Totally.
That's silly thinking.
It's like short sighted thinking.
It's like,
I appreciate your Har in the expression of racism,
but I don't,
I just think that the best way to approach it is to first of all,
lead by example.
Be someone who's you.
You would want to imitate,
you know,
be someone who you'd want an imitate is,
uh,
is a,
a great way to overcome a lot of things.
Uh,
like as far as like the way people interact with you,
everyone is interact.
Everyone who interacts with anybody is always influenced by someone's success or
failure.
I mean,
I never did coke cause I was around people who did coke and their lives fell
apart.
I was like,
well keep away from coke.
But I've been around people like really hard workers and really disciplined and
I get excited by them.
I get,
I get stimulated,
you know,
and I think we're,
we're entirely,
we're way more,
way more dependent upon the atmosphere of others and the,
the,
the inspiration of others than we liked to pretend we're way more,
way more.
And I think that one of the bad things about short sided like black and white
issues,
and I don't mean black and white in a literal sense.
I mean as far as um,
like someone never using a word,
you can never use that word.
It's like,
well the,
the human mind is capable of a lot of different subtleties and variations.
And when you're talking about language,
especially,
you're dealing with a lot of subtlety,
you're dealing with like some really funny things that go on with people.
And some of those funny things make personalities exciting.
Like Neal Brennan had is fucking hilarious joke where he was a,
he used to do this thing all the time with his friends in New York where he
would go,
uh,
what's,
what's going on with the weather today?
And they'd go,
Oh man,
snow.
And he'd go fucking niggers.
And if anybody knows Neal Brennan,
he's like one of the least racist human beings you'll ever meet in your life.
I mean,
he has a podcast.
It's all about interviewing successful black people.
Him and Moshe Kasher have that podcast,
the champs where almost all of it is like successful black artists,
successful black athletes.
Like he's not racist in the least.
He might hate white people,
you know,
but he's funny.
You know,
and that's what funny people do when you know they're not racist.
And it's hilarious.
You know,
you laugh cause you know him and you know me and it's like,
it's funny,
you know,
he said he was the fucking cocreative,
the Chappelle show.
I mean he's not racist.
Well he's just pointing a is pointing out and that's what a lot of humor does.
It points out things that were not aware of like this is how ridiculous some of
the scapegoat ism that we use.
Oh,
it's because,
and people have used,
oh it's the Jews,
it's the blacks,
it's blah,
blah,
blah.
It shows how ridiculous the snow is.
Completely unrelated.
And so that's why it's funny.
It's like,
it's funny because that's happened before all the time,
right.
It's,
it's obviously a huge exaggeration of it,
but it's,
it's hilarious.
But that's,
that's the problem with eliminating words.
You know,
you eliminate where you say,
he should never be able to say that.
I come on that moment that we just laughed.
I should never do.
I have to say the n bomb,
you know,
he said fucking in bombs like,
come on.
Really?
And he's like,
what we're doing?
That's silly.
There's a,
it's intent is the most critical aspect of human beings communicating with each
other.
What are you trying to get through?
What,
what is your intent?
What are you trying to say?
Like oftentimes,
like you'll hear people speak in political terms or in very measured terms and
instead of making you feel calm,
it actually makes you uneasy.
She's like,
Oh God,
I don't even know what the fuck this guy really feels like.
I'm getting this PC or this a red or a or,
um,
uh,
publicists version of who this person's thoughts are.
Who the,
who this guys,
what this guy's thoughts really are.
I'm not getting the true emotion.
The fact that we have to judge our politicians based on these really practice
staged events rather than real adversity.
You know,
like that's where we should be able to judge our politicians.
What happens when they're rolling for two hours and they're getting their ass
kicked?
Like how do they respond after that?
What happens when they do a psychedelic?
What happens when they do this thing?
That's how we should judge the character,
the people who are leading and back when these politicians emerged from amongst
the people they emerged because people understood that like that's a bad
motherfucker.
He can handle it if shit goes wrong.
Um,
you know,
I'm going to his house and then that guy was the leader back then.
But now it's not.
Yeah,
now it's just who's better at those fake speeches?
So hilarious.
I think,
you know,
we almost hot heartburn psychedelics too much,
but that's because we've done them.
That's the problem.
People have people who haven't done on the likes guys are idiots or it's just
talking about doing well.
Yeah,
drugs are the solution.
It's a fucking goddamn shortcut.
I'll tell you that's exactly what God damn giant shortcut.
But I think that if we did have some sort of an experience,
what even if it's just a physical trial,
like if you had to watch them,
you know,
go through a mud race together,
how would they push each other away?
Do they concentrate on their own performance?
They try to hold people down.
Like look,
look,
look Al Gore's grabbing his shoe laces,
he's on tying the guy shoots.
You know what I mean?
Like if you saw them,
do you saw their character,
a merge character under adversities form of it,
some form of competition.
You know,
it would be fascinating to see how these guys performed.
I think when you hear like Bill Clinton who I think is a very intelligent guy,
says he,
he would do these talks where he would talk about the difference between what
the Democrats have done,
the Republicans have done and it was very like team base we did is we lowered
the depths.
We did this,
we did that.
We did there.
Haven't been able to do it since.
It's like us and them and day in us.
And he was like constantly talks about this team thing that's going on.
You realize like he's in this weird competition with these people.
You know,
like this is like,
he's like gloating and you know,
he's looking at the scoreboard.
We're number one,
we're number one.
I mean that's essentially what you're doing and if you want to get elected in
this country and under,
especially those conditions back then,
maybe not as much now,
but it's,
you know,
it's kind of morphing in some weird place now.
That's what you had to do.
He had to have that mindset.
So that was the game keeps not that anymore.
No,
the game is the Goddamn Internet.
The Internet is the portal of consciousness,
the portal of information.
It's the portal of connectivity in a way that just didn't exist before.
So he's fucking guys are,
they're my fellow Americans.
Like,
come on man.
Like that shit is not an to keep flying is going to come a port and point in
time,
but we want to watch you go to the jungle.
How do you deal with mosquitoes when you're high as fuck?
You know,
like what I want to see.
What happens if you eat some mushrooms and sit in a quiet room by yourself?
I want to see,
I want to see what goes on in your mind when you eat a pot cookie and you think
you're going to die and then you climb into an isolation tank.
I want to know what the fuck goes on in there,
man.
What?
What kind of thoughts about your high school did you have?
Like what did you,
how do you feel about yourself now?
What do you do you,
are you happy with the momentum that you've created?
Would you like to trim back some of these fucking,
some of these roads that you've got the travel on?
What would you like to do?
Like would you do know who you are right now or you are a product of the
momentum of your past and I'm not sure.
It's hard to tell.
She got to see someone struggle.
You've got to see him.
That's the key.
30 seconds,
keep going.
Oh,
okay.
My feet hurt.
I got some gout,
something wrong my balls.
You know,
like you're going to see,
you're going to see who they really are.
Other than that,
that nice person in that nice suit with the perfect smile.
Yeah.
And I think that's the direction that things are going,
you know,
and I'm encouraged by that.
I think,
you know,
the Internet's already gotten rid of a lot of the hypocrisy because things get
found out.
You know,
the transparency has increased.
But as consciousness increases,
I think the demand for a conscious leader will become overwhelming.
And only when the demand for a conscious leader is there will one emerge and
actually succeed.
So,
you know,
instead of focusing on the politicians,
let's just focus on raising consciousness everywhere so that the demand is so
high that one will emerge to meet that demand.
It's also,
we're in a situation where as far as education goes,
as far as
the,
the roads,
as far as like food,
you know,
food comes at,
we're dealing with like these structures that are already there.
They're already there and people seek to improve them.
They seek to improve the,
the structures and the jail sentencing,
you know,
all the different bullshit that people hate about police brutality.
They see seek to improve those structures instead of like trying new one like
from scratch.
And that's what I think like when you see something like Waco,
Texas,
the Waco is obviously a bad idea.
What they did,
the Videon complex,
they stocked up,
weapons are shooting at the feds and they fucking some wild Texans running a
call.
It,
the guy was banging everybody's wife allegedly,
you know,
that's how it goes when it goes wrong,
but,
but the idea of creating a community,
organizing an engineering or community with resources,
including security is the dangerous thought.
Like you people go,
hey,
which trying to do,
you're trying to start your own army.
No,
we just have guns in case somebody fucks with us.
Oh,
that sounded like an army to me.
Well,
aren't we allowed to defend ourselves individually?
Individually?
You can have your own weapon that you could use as a home security device,
but what you can't do is get together with others and patrol your neighborhood
as a home security patrol and then a homeschool.
You have a neighborhood butcher.
Well,
he decided to have a citywide security team.
That sounds like an army boy.
Well,
we do have bulletproof tanks and laser beams,
but it's just to kill bad guys.
Like,
no,
no.
That's our job.
You Fuck,
you're getting in on the government's turned right and then they'll come down.
The feds will,
but fucking jackbooted thugs kicking your door,
flame thrower your kids and start from scratch.
Like,
look,
we told you no compounds.
Yeah,
no high fences.
No,
but no,
no more than 30 people with guns that live under one roof.
You just can't do it.
It's a fascinating idea,
but I think that you're going to see,
there's a town in Texas that I talked about this the other day and people
actually got to set up that I talked about it.
They fired the cops in 2012 hired a public or a private company to patrol the
streets.
Crime went down by 61%.
They,
the cops have no uh,
no financial vested interest in writing tickets.
Like they don't have quotas that they have to meet so they don't harass people
nearly as much and they actually patrol areas where there's crime and that
reduces crime.
Go figure.
And people are like,
hey man,
sounds like what you're talking about is fashion.
And we were talking about private police and security teams are gonna fuck them.
They're going to be FEMA camps everywhere you look or they're like every other
business and they become accountable for their actions in a way where,
you know,
you fire them and you hire a new team.
You know,
you just don't get locked into any ridiculous 30 year agreement when some police
department instead like have a security team.
That is,
it's,
it's beneficial to the community and people can maybe be a part of that security
team that are in the community.
That'd be crazy.
Huh?
Have actually people in the community patrolling the community and getting paid
by the community to do that.
A lot of unemployed people that might make good cops and you could do all this
shit and in a,
in a,
in a way where it's profitable without having all these goddamn quotas that
these people have to meet.
And these weird pressures that are on people that are in law enforcement.
The more we can decentralize the,
the structures,
you know,
go from federal rules to state rules.
We've already seen the benefits of that in a state like Colorado where they're
able to make their own rules,
you know?
That's great.
And then from there,
if you go back even to the way the towns can decide,
you know,
what the town should do and is the smaller you get,
the more opportunity you have for these great situations
to develop.
Yeah.
And I think one of the paradigm cases,
I read this book called the fifth sacred thing and it shows what happens when a
Utopian society clashes with the Dystopian society.
It's a,
it's a fiction novel,
but the really cool part is seeing what the Utopian structure looks like.
Like what a model of a totally cool place to live would be if everything from
the family structure to the rules to how they decide things to how they defend
themselves,
to how everything works,
what they celebrate,
what the rituals are amongst that.
And it's cool to be able to look at that and say,
you know,
that's possible.
We just have to allow people to gather and create their own situation if they
want to.
It doesn't always have to go where the owner,
it's all top down and the owner fucks all the teenage girls just because that's
happened time and time again.
It doesn't need it.
It has to happen that I think it's likely to happen last now that it's ever
happened before.
And I also don't think that it has to be centrally located.
And I think that one of the things that we're experiencing with,
um,
this exchange of information on the Internet is you're finding a lot of
likeminded people that are also trying to improve themselves.
They're also being super honest about who they are,
who they were trying to improve themselves and they get inspiration from other
people like you or like anybody else that's out there that is also on that same
path of self improvement and honesty and I think we find each other's cyber Lee,
I think we don't even necessarily have to live on your rye favors blind.
I think what he's got is pretty sweet.
That's probably the ideal way to do it,
but if it's not available,
it's also happening whether you like it or not.
It's happening throughout the world.
I experiencing the,
I experienced that at,
at these shows or these standup shows,
you meet these people that are due to lost 150 pounds.
Like whoa.
And you know,
changed my life.
I started doing this,
I started doing that.
He Kale are forking Kettlebell in my back pocket.
You know,
you meet these fucking people and you realize like there's a lot of folks out
there that are also trying to,
they're trying to better themselves and they're trying to like tune into that
vibe and they're finding other people like that online that trying to tune into
that,
that vibe of we're all figuring this out,
man.
No one's perfect,
no one's got a lock on this crazy life.
You know,
spend less time pointing fingers at other people and shaming them for,
you know,
making a fat joke and more time getting your own shit together and we'll have a
way better spot to hang out in.
Yeah,
we will all have a way better spot,
like the cost across the globe.
I think that's happening,
man.
People say I'm too optimistic,
but man,
I don't know.
I,
I see it,
I see it in action.
I see it at these shows.
I see it all the time.
I agree with what's happening that I,
that I see is you have your nuclear tribe,
those 15 people,
you say that you could give him $1 million and never even blinking an eye.
You wouldn't even get nervous about it,
you know,
and,
and so will you start to develop these nuclear tribes and then getting
gatherings together,
you know,
I think is another important thing.
Like say,
hey everybody,
let's all meet for these five days and hang out and have fun.
And,
and I think that'll be a cool aspect of consciously bringing into that.
But then you have like the mega tribe beyond the nuclear tribe and that's like
all the people listening to the show where you know,
they're sharing a certain sentiment.
So it's not like your total strangers when you meet,
there's a part of you that's already connected and like you see that at burning
man,
you know,
the mere fact that they're at burning man means that they subscribed,
subscribed to a certain amount of belief.
Generally.
Of course,
there's probably some outliers,
but generally you can meet someone there and know like,
all right,
you're going to be,
you know,
you're going to be cool with me.
You're not going to call me a dick.
You know,
hopefully,
hopefully you've got them in a bad patch of burning man is rogue community.
Yeah.
Dirty,
sad.
They would feel themselves,
you know,
they would feel weird in that because the whole collective would end up trying
to force him out,
like pus in the skin.
It would become a pimple that would eventually pop and bail the fuck out of
there.
You know,
the collective organism would reject it.
Yeah.
And I think to things like burning man and the growth of that,
which is so big,
it gets sold out every year.
Like in advance.
It's like,
it's letting,
there's,
there's a giant community of people that also would like to go to burning man,
but can't make it there.
You know,
they might have obligations or family or whatever they have to do,
but they want to go there but certain react like it's not Mac our God damn,
I don't have to fucking go around that square.
And there's no,
it's a nowhere place in the desert.
It's literally nothing there.
Well that's why it's a good spot to go cause nobody fucks with you.
But really it'd be way better if we did it in Hawaii.
Folks.
Let's just fuck it all.
Go to mally man.
Malley's way better than the desert.
I totally,
you know,
but they would get mad dirty hippies.
But you gotta,
you gotta wear dust masks when you're out there.
But I think the point you're making is take your 15 people and have your own
little burning man where you all bring stuff,
you all share stuff,
you don't worry about who's paying for what.
Everybody contributed and you're all hanging out and experience that together in
your own way.
You don't need to go to black rock Nevada,
right.
To do that.
You can go to,
you know,
the fucking camping somewhere out in you just put up some tents and just hang,
you know?
Yeah.
But what Bernie man seems to be as like a bat signal,
someone throws up and they all hate there.
You know,
it's the super tribe meeting.
It's what the aborigines did.
It Ulu at heir's rock.
You know,
like every once in a while you go to this one fucking spot and it's five days a
crazy dream time.
And did you reduce echoing through the whole place and it's a celebration and
then you go back to your smaller units.
Let your freak flag fly.
How about we do this?
How about we,
I've been thinking about this and you've been thinking about this too about us
getting a ranch in Texas.
If we got,
if we got a ranch in Texas.
Okay.
If we got like a a hunting ranch in Texas that we also had yearly psychedelic
rituals.
First of all,
how quick would we get co opted by?
The feds when they're there,
they're like,
there's a fucking desk just got assigned to it right now and a coffee.
You're on this lesson and I was fucking new stream channel.
It's fucking hippies.
Yeah you do that.
Like have like a,
a virgin aversion rather of burning man and at a ranch Texas,
it's,
I mean it's definitely feasible green people though.
You guys are going to,
sure,
sure.
And I are anonymous to crawl up the ass.
Get those folks.
When the Black Internet,
is that what's called the dark internet?
Sorry.
Well if we just picked a spot,
it doesn't even have to be a place that we own so there's no liability.
That's a good move.
We just pick a spot somewhere and we say,
hey,
all people who liked what we were just talking about,
let's meet at this general area for these four days and then you know,
see how it goes.
But we gotta be somewhere where you can be high as fuck and not be in danger.
That's why the deserts good cause there's nothing out there.
You can't go wandering off in the woods and get eaten by a bear.
Like if we did it in Alberta,
we started losing hippies.
Yeah,
he started getting buried out there.
You hear something,
this is a drum circle.
Don't worry about their,
some of these things like I think one of them is called envision and it's in
Costa Rica and this beautiful fucking place.
I mean there's places around the world that we could pick that are,
that are cool with stuff.
I mean Costa Rica's cool with a law SCA with a Bogo with,
they're not going to fuck with you too much.
Traveling to other countries is fucking problematic.
Shit hits the fan.
You've got to get back to the good old us of a with the quickness
as that plane is.
Fuck all that star spangled banner Shay,
you'd be very happy to pledge of allegiance once that plane was leaving and you
hear guns go off behind your plane and Costa Rica,
you realize right as the insurgency takes over the new government.
Take care.
Good luck with the Iowaska retreat.
I'm going to go to Miami for a weekend for sure.
Drink on the beach.
There's good and bad and all this stuff.
They just uh,
I think people are getting it together though.
I really do.
I agree.
I feel it.
I might be delusional,
but I think at least in the,
to the people that I'm in contact with,
they're getting it and they're there.
I feel like they're spreading and when I say getting it or you get it,
what I mean by that is this idea of everybody trying to improve themselves and
people just kind of being cool with each other and people being honest about all
their attributes.
The deposit gives the negatives,
all that stuff and working it out together.
Man.
And part of getting it is knowing that you know,
nothing really,
you know,
it's just accepting the fact that we know incrementally less nothing and
sometimes maybe even more nothing cause the expanse of what is possible to know
increases,
you know?
And just understanding that we're just trying to figure it out to the best
fucking way that we can.
You know?
That's it.
When I was young and stupid,
I was very insecure about things I didn't know.
Like I wanted to pretend I knew things so I didn't know like yeah I know that
you know,
like it would be like somebody would bring up something.
I'm like,
I know that.
But I felt like somehow or another there was some weakness and saying like,
what does that,
you know,
which is like I love to do that now.
Like my favorite thing to like,
I don't need to know first of all now I'm smart enough or at least some
accumulated enough information to know you can't know
everything.
I get stupid.
That's why I love what I talked to someone like Brian Cox was his genius.
Fucking scientists do to work at the large Hadron collider and teaches fucking
science to the whole world.
We asked him something he doesn't know.
He goes,
I don't know.
I don't know about that.
Like,
oh great.
I love that.
That's fucking giant.
That's important because one of the things that plagues human beings and their
development is this lack of admitting to failure.
There's lack of admitting to not knowing something this to this.
It's fear of your own ignorance and denial of it to the point where you're
posturing in front of other people.
That's all eliminated by pot cookies.
You can,
you can get rid of all that shit.
Well,
having something to defend because you're,
again,
it's this illusion of vulnerability.
I need to defend these beliefs because if I don't have them,
what am I?
What am I without being right?
You know,
do I love myself?
If I'm not the smartest person in the room?
Well,
you know,
you got to let all that shit go.
You know,
and you've got to build your foundation on the rocks instead of these,
these sand castles.
Cause that'll never fulfill you.
If driving around in a certain car makes you feel good or if being right and
belittling people on the Internet makes you feel good,
it will never actually work longterm to make you feel good.
You'll,
it will be this hole that the more you throw in at the bigger the whole gets.
You know,
you got to find your own internal ways to feel that good and to feel that way.
Everything else is just a sidetrack that's taking you backwards.
Yeah.
And it goes back to what we're talking about where people just automatically
look to get in disagreements with people if they feel that they're on different
team.
You know,
people that are on a different idea.
I meet people,
the Philadelphia Eagles,
he used to beat the fuck out of people so bad and they're at their games.
Like they broke some guys a leg and a fucking stairwell cause he was a fan of
the other team.
Like,
like that type.
I mean that's not that tribal issue.
You know what you're talking about.
Like praying on the worst aspects of tribalism.
That's,
uh,
that's something that needs to be addressed in schools.
Like we need to,
we can explain like these are why you have these weird instincts to be in teams
and the form gangs because he really used to have to do that to stay alive.
Right.
But you know,
now we don't,
we don't have to do that shit anymore.
Nope.
All right.
Fuckers.
We've reached the end.
This is three hours of love with Aubrey Marcus and Joe Rogan.
Uh,
we have nothing more to tell you.
we hope you enjoyed this.
Uh,
we have an audit podcast so you can listen to do you have your own podcast as
well to the warrior poet project.
And you have the Onnit podcast,
which are,
they're separate
completely.
Sorry,
I go a little deeper into the kind of spiritual psychedelic realms on my own.
And then
on it is about just improving human performance.
Human optimization
you fucks on at.com.
O.
N N I t go there,
enjoy,
read up.
And if you're an Austin,
Texas,
there is an actual on it,
Jim.
Now that's open and it is fucking spectacular.
State of the art.
Super Dope.
Full Cryo therapy in the fucking
house.
Um,
tell people about that and how do they get to that?
And I actually worked there.
It's so funny.
People come and they're like,
Aubrey,
you're here.
Well,
no shit over here.
This is where I work,
you know?
So if you go by,
say hello,
you know,
I'll be there.
I'll be happy to say a to you on a.com oh,
and in it.
All right,
we'll see you guys next week.
Lots of funny gas coming up next week.
And until then,
much love take care everybody.
Okay.